Package is supposed to be out with you.
Five,
four,
three,
two.
Ben Greenfield is gentlemen and Robo.
So it's been a lot of fun hanging out
with you for the last 44 minutes.
A sick game you out.
Yeah,
it's pretty fun,
right?
I need to build a really,
really big like 67 yard long living room
to,
to put my big screen in now.
Yeah.
That thing is crazy.
This,
we're talking about this game called
techno hunt that were just so,
dude,
you,
you are an interesting fucking guy.
You do a lot of weird shit.
I would no,
thank you.
I think,
yeah,
no,
it's good.
Yes.
It's a compliment when I say yeah,
interesting is a good thing.
But your,
um,
like your background,
you were just telling me this is very
fascinating.
Like you,
you live way the fuck out in the middle
of nowhere.
Well,
it's Kinda,
I mean it's spokane,
spokane,
ha.
I mean we have like a theater.
You're off the grid and we have
restaurants.
They're actual people there who
Yeah.
And there's a theater there.
There's a little five and dime store.
At a general store,
a spoke cans,
a normal place.
It's pretty normal.
You're,
you're totally off the grid.
Well,
up at our house we are,
you know,
we're,
we're in solar panels and,
well,
and the way I have it set up is we eased
in power from the local municipal power.
But if that goes out then it hits the
solar inverters and we're full solar.
So then there's that.
There's like a battery power in the
garage that stores a solar because we're
on a,
we're on like a north facing slope,
so you get sun from 10 to two.
So we can't collect a lot of solar,
but you stored in the battery.
So it's,
it's there.
So you've gotta be very judicious with
your laptop use.
Yeah,
well we do want to go off the grid.
It's a stupid home.
So there's,
there's no Wifi,
there's no bluetooth.
So everything's like,
it's,
it's hardwired metal shoulder,
the ethernet cable that's through the
whole house because I don't like to have
like Wifi signals bouncing around.
I just really,
I don't feel good.
I've always wondered about that.
What is that doing to us?
Well,
apparently I just actually just read,
there's a,
there's a really good new book that came
out is called like that the non tin foil
hat guide to Emf I think is,
is the full title of the book.
But it goes into this idea of what are
called voltage gated calcium channels on
your cell membrane and all those
actually get affected by Wifi.
And apparently you see like a,
like a change in the electro chemical
balance across the actual membrane in
response to things like Wifi.
Apparently Bluetooth affects red blood
cells and I haven't seen,
I haven't seen a lot of like actual,
you know,
in Vivo research on that.
But I know that I feel better when I
don't have like the Wifi router going
or,
you know,
I,
I turn off all my,
all,
everything at night.
There's kill switches and all the
bedrooms.
So it's bait.
You walk into the house and it's just
super clean.
Oh,
everything's HEPA air filters,
negative ion generators,
no Wifi,
no bluetooth.
We structure all the water that comes in
from the,
well,
so it's the same now,
Scott like that.
Uh,
have you heard of structured water
before?
I just heard about it because Eddie
Bravo just got that installed in his
jet.
It's kind of cool.
I mean the idea behind it,
there's this,
this cat up at University of Washington
named doctor Gerald and he has done this
research that shows like in plants or
vessels like blood vessels for example,
there's an exclusion zone of water.
I mean there's like a positive charge on
the inside and a negative charge on the
outside and that might be backwards.
It might be positive on the outside,
negative on the inside.
But either either way it causes fluid to
move through vessels in a way that
allows it to move more easily.
Like,
like the water is actually charged.
So apparently when you drink structured
water hydrates the sell a little bit
better,
Huh?
Yeah,
it sounds like,
and that's,
that's apparently how,
how water moves through plants.
That's one of those things that you hear
and then like you talked to a scientist
and they go,
no.
Yeah.
And they get mad.
Well,
I interviewed that,
I interviewed that guy,
Gerald Pollack.
And he has compare basically what he's
compared to like how it moves in,
in glass tubes and how can you structure
it and you watch it like the water moves
up through the glass tube way,
way better.
And then I interviewed this guy,
uh,
Thomas Cowan and he talks about how the
heart is not really a pump or it doesn't
act as much like a pump as we're led to
believe.
And so if you,
if you drink structured water,
apparently the blood moves better
through the vessels.
So I haven't seen a ton of research on
it,
but I structured my water just in,
cause it's cheap.
It's like a,
it's like this tiny little like plastic
piece that you put on on your,
on your water.
What exactly is it doing?
So the water passes through a series of
glass beads like vortex is it?
So after it.
So it comes out of my,
well and I've got,
I tested my water and I've got a like a
bacteria based iron and high levels of
manganese.
Like,
I thought,
well water was just all like pristine,
clear,
like,
you know,
like if you drink out of a spring on top
of a mountain,
but,
uh,
apparently there's,
there's crap in the well water.
So I filter it and then after it all
filters,
it passes through the structured water
filter.
I would ask that you would get some
stuff in the water because if somewhere
along the line there's like a dead
animal or beaver fever.
Yeah.
Was dead animals all over my head,
just piled everywhere.
Carcasses.
Careful not,
but well then the other thing is like
what I get concerned about is,
you know,
you see like glyphosate and herbicides
and pesticides,
they get spread over the crops and I
live in farmland territory,
right?
So I'm on this north facing slope and
there's all like these farms above me.
So I figure if that's dropping down
through the ground into that water,
I might be getting some of it.
So I filter.
Yeah,
that totally makes sense.
I know a guy who got bone cancer because
he lived off of a golf course and uh,
the golf course is constantly spraying
stuff on the golf course and it got into
the water supply and a bunch of powder.
They select getting bone cancer.
Oh really?
Like it happened to more people at a ton
of people in the neighborhood got
cancer.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's scary.
Sharese know what I tell people is um,
like people who don't have a well and
you just live off the municipal water
supplies.
You use a reverse osmosis water filter
cause it's a really,
really fine filtration but it takes
everything out.
Like it takes the bad stuff and the good
stuff out.
So you want to add minerals back in
after you filter the water.
So you get a reverse and you could buy
these on like Amazon.
So like a reverse osmosis filter with
what's called re mineralization or you
can just use reverse osmosis and then
use like trace liquid minerals or you
know,
sea salt or anything else to add
electrolytes back into.
A lot of people will put like a pinch of
Himalayan salt.
I go through so much salt.
I use this,
this stuff called Mexican Salt Kalema
salt.
I have in my,
I was actually at a steak house last
night.
People make fun of me cause I pulled up
my big white bag of salt and I just
sprinkle it on everything.
But I'm a,
I'm a fiend for salt.
I love salt.
It's very good for you.
And unfortunately there's been a
terrible myth.
It's been perpetrated a long time ago.
That song gives you high blood pressure
and it kills you.
And that's a,
that's a real tragedy because that's one
of those ones that it was,
it was spread in like probably,
what was it,
the sixties or seventies when they
started telling people that salt causes
high blood pressure and no clue.
People still repeated today and they
don't understand that it's an essential
mineral.
Well there's a,
there's a new book out about this.
I forget the name of the book about
something.
Have you heard of this book?
I've heard of the book,
but I don't know the name,
but it depends too because um,
I used to do racing 14 timex.
I used to these iron man triathlons and
they'd bring people in to test us and
they would do sweat sodium analyses
where you actually get a patch put on
your skin and it measures the amount of
sodium released over x surface area of
skin.
And then there's an algorithm that terms
like how much total sweat you lose say
per hour during exercise and,
and some people lose a copious amount of
sodium in their sweat and some lose
barely any at all.
So you have like a sodium conservation
mechanism that differs from person to
person.
So there might be some people who store
salt really well who might actually get
higher blood pressure if they,
if they consume a lot of salt.
So if you're in a massive excess of salt
and your time,
and my numbers were off the charts
though in terms of how much sodium was I
was losing,
which is probably why it feels so good.
Well that makes sense.
So you're sweating so much,
right?
I mean it's just going right through
your body now going to,
it tastes amazing.
Yeah,
I'm happy to die of high blood pressure
just because of this salt.
Just a big fan.
I love kosher so I used to at least to
pay it and they pay like Roman soldiers
and sure.
And so I don't,
if we went to war for salt,
I take salt.
I mean it's really kind of amazing.
Then it was just less than a 200 years
ago that they figured out how to like
make refrigerators and I mean as a
frigerator from the 1930s I think it was
when,
when did they first invent those things
and then before that they had ice boxes.
You'd have to get a chunk of ice from
somewhere,
right.
Have to get me to store stuff.
And before that they just use salt.
And I've heard,
I don't know if this is true,
but I heard that if you come from an
area,
like if your ancestry is from an area
where they did a lot of that fermenting,
pickling,
curing,
salting,
that you have more robust sodium loss
mechanisms like which would make sense
for me.
Like I'm northern European heritage.
I did a lot of like pickling,
salting,
curing.
So I would lose more salt than somebody
who might've come from let's say like a
sub Saharan African or South East Asian
or somewhere where they might not have
been using so much salt.
Yeah,
that totally makes sense.
Yeah.
So this Wifi thing,
I want to go back to that.
Um,
cause I've always wondered there's,
there's not a long history of use of
human use of Wifi.
And one of the things sounds so stem
cells,
we're talking about a lot,
a lot of studies on that other 90 year
old dad is running around.
They've been doing himself,
right,
exactly.
Yeah.
But the Wifi,
like when it sounds hippy dippy,
but if you go somewhere like Prince of
Wales,
Alaska and you're on a mountain top,
it feels different.
Oh it totally does.
No radio.
There's no Wifi,
there's no direct TV's getting to you.
There's nothing and that fee,
it feels different up there.
You're also,
I mean like your grounding and earthing,
right.
And you're,
you're uh,
you're breathing a lot more negative
ions cause you're outside in the fresh
air.
And we don't have all the emails jumping
out from your inbox.
There's,
there's a lot of confounding variables.
But I mean,
all I know and I test a,
you're,
you're retested heart rate variability.
No,
it gets the,
um,
do you know what that is?
HRV.
A lot of athletes use it,
but I don't know much about what does it
miss the Inter beat individuality,
like the variation in the amount of time
in between each beat of your heart.
So it's not like how fast your heart is
beating and how much time is in between
each heartbeat.
So you can measure that and you're
supposed to have like slight beat to
beat variation in how much time is
between each heartbeat.
And if you have that,
that's high heart rate variability.
So you can use that to track your
readiness to train your recovery.
Right.
So I use,
I use like a ring like this or I'll do
like a heart rate strap in the morning.
So aura or a ring actually,
have you heard of this thing?
No,
but do just going out of my a cracker
jack box.
It's a,
it's a power.
It's a power ring.
So mood ring.
I've seen one of those,
someone,
someone sent me something,
they don't just use rings,
right?
There's like other methods of measuring
it as well.
Or like you can use a bluetooth enabled
heart rate monitor strap.
That's what it,
that's what I used to do is you wake up
in the morning,
you put on the stopping and test your
heart rate variability and it tells you,
you know,
if it's low you might say,
okay well today is going to be like a a
yoga day or an easy swim or walk in the
sunshine and if it's high then that
would be a day where you'll do like
kettle bell training or a wad or
whatever is it you're going to do.
And then the other thing you could use
it for is if you,
you'll sometimes purposefully get it
low,
like have some athletes that I train
where we'll work them into a state where
they've got really low heart rate
variability.
And then what happens is you taper,
right?
Like you recover,
you rest,
you super compensate.
So you see a bounce back of nervous
system recovery.
And you can use that to purposefully
adjust the training.
Yeah.
And if you train through a low hrv for
too long,
you can predict illness.
You can predict injury.
So it's a cool way to track training and
you can even,
you can look at,
um,
there's a high frequency in a low
frequency when you're saying you could
predict illness and injury meaning
meaning like my hrv is low but,
but screw it,
I'm going to go train anyways.
But you do that day after day you get
injured.
And the weird thing is that you can have
no musculoskeletal soreness,
right?
Cause a lot of time that subsides,
you know,
delayed onset muscle soreness.
You see that disappear after like 48
hours.
And if you've crushed yourself like a,
we could talk about this letter if you
want,
but I've been doing a single set to
failure or a single set to failure
exercises where it's just like a 15
minute long workout,
but it's just full on isometrics.
As hard as you can go for 60 seconds to
two of metrics isometrics.
So you're pushing against,
it's a,
it's like this force plate machine that
you push against and you just generate
as much force as you can and it ties to
your iphone and it alerts you when
you've dropped off 60% of what you
originally producing at the beginning of
the set.
And then that's it sets done game over.
So you might do deadlift,
squat,
press overhead,
press pull down,
and that's the whole workout.
And then you're just recovering in
between each of those sets.
So this plate,
I mean how you doing a dead lift with a
plate?
It's a force plate.
So for example,
you're standing in Ohio like a bar,
okay.
That you're holding onto and the bar is
attached to the force plate via two
stands on either like two pillars on
either side of the bar and you pull the
bar and then the force plate detects how
much force you're polling and what
positions.
Let's say you're standing on top of the
force plate,
you're supposed to choose the hardest
position of each exercise.
So like half,
if I'm,
if I'm bench pressing,
it's like my elbows are slightly bent.
Just near the top or a squatting.
It's like the knees are bent that about
30 40 degrees.
So,
so you get into that position,
then you generate as much force as
possible for 60 seconds or not.
When I first did it,
I was at 30 seconds,
now I can go a little bit over a minute
where I can continue to generate as much
force as possible before it drops off to
just 60% of what I was originally
produced.
It's a,
it's a cool,
efficient way to train,
but you don't get that sore afterwards.
Right?
So musculoskeletal soreness is not a
good indicator of recovery in many
cases.
And that's where this hrv thing comes in
is your nervous system,
right?
Your central nervous system,
your neuromuscular system can be really
beat up after a workout even if the
soreness has subsided.
So that's where you use something like
hrv and you can say,
okay,
well I'm not sore but my hrv is still
low.
So this is going to be an easy day for
me.
I'm sorry to act like a moron,
but explain that one more session.
So if your um,
if your body is not sore but your hrv is
low,
it's,
what is it showing?
What's an indication of?
So if your body is not sore but your hrv
is low,
Hrv is measuring your nervous system
recovery.
Right?
So,
so you might not be fully recovered.
So what I'm saying it's like
musculoskeletal soreness or discomfort
is not necessarily the best indicator of
whether you're fully recovered.
You have to test the nervous system too.
That's so weird.
That's what I'm hearing.
Someone that can edit jarvey measurement
comes in and and coming full circle.
I've noticed when I do those morning
measurements and I'm traveling or I've
got the Wifi enabled at my house,
my hrv is low so it's affecting my
nervous system somehow is the why do you
think the Wifi is a mind fuck.
Do you think it's really doing something
too?
I think is doing something but then
there's in this room there's the placebo
effect.
I feel it.
I feel real say that's trying to feel
it.
That's why you're a moron right now.
You've got the Wifi going,
what's going on Jamie?
What do you got the hrv off of my eye.
Oh you just t what'd you use?
The fingertip.
My Apple Watch the Apple Watch tests.
Your hrv.
So it's been doing it for the whole time
I've had it on,
but it's paradoxical because the apple
watch is making Wifi so it's so
confusing.
Yeah,
no,
that's what I was talking about.
This,
this ring,
uh,
bought this in Finland like three years
ago because I wanted like a body
tracking device.
I want to track my hrv and I want to
track my sleep cycles.
But I don't like sleeping all night
cause like I sleep with my kind of like
my hand tucked down by my Dick,
you know,
like in,
in,
by my cry.
I don't want something just like sleep
like this.
I kinda,
I sleep on my side,
my hands tucked underneath me and there
and lily would be like,
my right hand is right down around my
bowls basically while I'm sleeping and I
didn't want something just like blasting
me.
That makes sense.
Sleeping.
So cause it was,
if it was on my wrist or on my finger or
wherever.
So this has like a built in computer and
you can put it in airplane mode and
it'll still collect all the hrv data and
everything else.
Then when you want to take it out of
airplane mode and sync it to your phone
and upload all your sleep data or your
hrv data or anything else,
you can do it.
So,
so that's,
that's why I wear this ring instead of
like a fitbit or jawbone or,
or,
or Jamie's stupid Apple Watch.
I never know whether or not being
ridiculous with this stuff.
Like with worrying about phones being a
man like,
but cancer,
you know,
cause it's somebody,
some dude told me that once that he got
cancer,
I think it was testing the cancer side
and the guy was saying,
do you keep your phone in your right
pocket?
He's,
I guess I do.
The doctor was telling him that.
I was like,
how the fuck does the doctor know?
Like this is not proven stuff.
This is all real speculation,
right?
I mean it's tricky because,
I mean you can say about the bone cancer
on the golf course,
right.
But,
but a lot of people that,
I think there's a class action lawsuit
it there,
cause I think they tested the water and
there was whatever the fuck the stuff
that they use for fertilizer or
pesticides.
That's what I was telling you.
I was concerned about the,
the Dick cancer thing because those stem
cells like a stem cells into your Dick.
Well,
for the past three,
so men's health magazine just had me
write this article called New Year New
Dick where they have me,
I'm sorry.
So you get them.
It's got a,
it's the issue with Marky Mark Wahlberg
on the [inaudible] on the cover.
How appropriate.
Yeah.
Like how to make a small Dick Bigger.
Right.
But marky mark on the,
on the cover and now he can,
he can beat me with his,
with his four foot tall.
Fisticuffs uh,
anyways though.
So they have me go around and doing
everything that I could do to enhance
sexual performance or increase the size
of your deck or increased blood flow or
increased orgasm quality or you know,
they just wanted to find out where
everything from like fricking gas
station,
Dick Pills to which by the way,
those things do not have it.
And then what they say they have in
them.
What do you think?
So,
so they,
you know,
they say like epimedium and your role
come a long jack and they're really
horny goat weed Algebra.
Yeah.
It's basically for consult benefil
right.
The active ingredient in Cialis or
Viagra and then a,
a Phaedra and copious amounts of
caffeine.
So I would take these things and just a
little,
I feel like my head was gonna explode.
I mean it's,
it's like drinking 10 cups of coffee.
Yeah.
We have a,
a friend of ours who predicted
accurately that Jon Jones was taken
those things when he pissed hot cause he
was like,
those things have everything in them.
And he's like a John Jones does coke.
He goes,
I guarantee he's taken dick pills
actually entertaining to read because
it's all like the like,
it's like arena,
Chinese fortune cookie,
right?
Maximum Potency Vigara and everything's
spelled wrong.
Uh,
but the,
uh,
so they have me doing that.
They did analysis of the ingredients.
Did you actually get it tested?
No,
no.
We,
we went to all these labs.
They wouldn't let us actually test,
but apparently the FDA has tested them.
And if you go to the fda.gov website,
they have like these,
these warnings out about the actual
ingredient.
We took,
the five that they had warnings about
and tested them and the day and day,
um,
yeah,
you don't feel well.
You feel like your head's gonna explode
and your hands get all cold and clammy.
And some of them say,
I don't know why,
but they say to take them in the
morning.
Right.
Which doesn't to me makes sense.
But you take him in the morning and so
you just feel completely screwed up like
the whole morning.
It's like you're just mainlining coffee.
So they did that.
They did.
Um,
have you heard of this?
Like acoustic sound wave therapy for
your Dick.
I'm serious.
So you're going to answer,
no,
I haven't said this.
This is a clinic in Florida.
It was called gainswave and you'd go
down to Florida.
We go down there and uh,
and I walk in and the first thing they
do is they hand me this like syringe
full of the numbing cream and I'm
supposed to just like put it everywhere.
And so I,
I smeared it,
you know,
my balls,
my like I just went everywhere cause I
didn't really know what they were,
what they were going to do and I wanted,
I want it all,
all shields activated going to go to,
into this thing.
So I walk into the room and,
and my Dick's all numb.
They had me lay down and so my legs are
splayed.
I'm on this exam room table and this gal
comes in and she's got like this giant
won attached to a machine and they do
this for women too by the way.
They put like a condom on the end of it
and,
and she just basically goes to town for
like 20 minutes.
Like a Jackhammer was like everywhere
around 20 minutes supposedly.
Yeah.
Supposedly it breaks open old blood
vessels and builds new blood vessels and
once the numbing cream wears off you're
supposed to to perform a lot better.
And then they combine this,
you know how we were,
we were talking about like with your
shoulder if you inject it you should do
like electro stammer vibration or
something to get the injection deeper
into the tissue.
So you think same thing with this,
they do the PRP.
So they do prp into your deck and then
they followed up and you get,
you get a nerve block first.
I actually,
I thought,
I don't know why I thought they put the
needle just like right in the pee hole,
which to me made sense but it doesn't
really,
I mean you want it in the actual tips.
So they actually go like up where the
dick attaches like the tissue at the
top,
two nerve blocks on either side and then
the prp and later on,
like a couple months later,
the Hemi do stem cells.
They actually extracted like four months
later from my back and we did a stem
cell injection.
But this acoustic sound wave therapy,
uh,
with the PRP,
like it wears off and you literally just
like get boners all the time,
like,
like all night long for like a month.
So the acoustic sound therapy's supposed
to be breaking up.
Blood vessel breaks open old board
vessels,
gainswave procedure breaks up plaque
formation in blood vessels and
stimulates the growth of new blood
vessels in the penis,
low intensity extra Kapore iol shockwave
therapy.
That's going to sell a lot of,
uh,
of procedures.
I like the drawing we shot before and
after.
Before your veins real tired.
Yeah,
before it looks like,
like an old hunched over man.
Then all of a sudden vigor.
It looks like a bodybuilding saying.
Yeah,
I used to do bodybuilding.
So is that horrible sport?
Do you think it's real?
Do you think that's really doing
something?
I have worked for me and I worked for me
in the,
um,
so yeah,
the,
the gas station,
Dick Pills,
they do the acoustic sound wave therapy,
but the [inaudible] injections,
they had me do like the,
uh,
knowledge stem cells with about stem
cells,
stem cells.
But that mean that not everybody's going
to be able to do that,
but that was the best bar.
None.
Like they,
so I went down to Florida and again,
Florida,
I don't know what I think is cause all
the old people live in Florida.
Like Dale,
all the people like hunched over the
steering wheel is there,
but all the guys have great Dick's.
They can't drive.
They have their blinker on for like two
miles before they turn,
but their dicks are primed.
So the,
um,
the stem cell thing was that the US stem
cell clinic in Florida and I went in
there and they extract all the fat for
me.
They took the fat on my back.
And what they do is they,
they have,
um,
it's called an enzymatic process where
they use something that breaks down the
Collagen in the fat and then they have
the stem cells that get separated from
the fat.
And apparently it's a very,
very high in these angiogenic like,
like vascular vessel building,
uh,
compounds.
And so then you get that it,
it's high in the,
um,
Mesenchymal,
the MSC,
the MSC cells,
which,
which are supposedly the very good ones
to inject in.
So I injected those,
um,
or I had a doctor in spokane,
so they shipped him to spokane on ice
and they show up at my house at like
7:00 AM right.
Because you got to get them delivered
the same day.
And then I had my appointment at the
doctor at 9:00 AM and I went to the
doctor and you know,
very,
it was like Deja Vu from Florida.
Like I go and do the,
do the numbing.
Yeah,
no,
you're going to do this.
Oh yeah.
I called him and I want it was kind of
friends with the doctor.
Yeah.
There's a picture,
I think there's a picture of him in the
mega,
cause they put all sorts of crazy
pictures in the magazine because they
haven't given like infrared light on my
balls.
And I have look this big thing called
the [inaudible] that they had me
standing in front of every day.
Like I Jack my light,
I'll tell you about the stem cells and
I'll tell you what's the chance that,
because it's crazy.
Um,
so the uh,
the stem cells,
I went to this doctor in spokane and he
injected these,
these stem cells from my fat after
they've grown for like several in this
case,
I think they were down there for like
eight weeks,
but I mean they,
they can do same day injections.
But for me,
I didn't have enough fat cause for me it
was right in the middle of,
I raced professionally and also of
course racing.
So I'm just like lean as hell as I go in
there.
So they could,
they could barely get enough fat,
so they had to grow them for a longer
period of time.
A lot of times they can inject same day.
So I went into spokane,
uh,
at this clinic and Spokane,
La,
new integrative clinic.
It's like this osteopathic medical
clinic with all these,
you know,
nice receptionist when you walk in the
door.
And this,
this,
this doctor who,
uh,
he's done stem cell injections before,
but he never actually injected them into
someone's deck.
So it was kinda like the Guinea pig for
this.
Do you have to explain to him what areas
you're supposed to do?
He researched it and I think he actually
talked to the folks at the stem cell
clinic beforehand and make sure that
they were on the,
on the same page.
Then when I fly all the way back down to
Florida,
it's super inconvenient and it's just a
deck,
right?
They'll make more Sunday.
They're growing kidneys and ears.
They'll grow Dick Someday.
So I'm,
so I got an injected and that was,
um,
uh,
first of all look like it got like run
over by a semi truck for like two days.
It was like all black and blue or the
injection you serve was,
yeah,
yeah.
I'd be super nervous.
Like,
what do we got infected?
It could've gotten infected.
Cancer.
I've had Marissa and I would not wish
Murcia on your Dick.
I need get mercy a triathlon.
I,
I got it.
This was at though at the wildflower
triathlon,
like coming back,
my flight got delayed and I was covering
all these kids like an off road
triathlon and I had all these scrapes
and wounds and I think,
I think my layover was in Vegas,
I don't remember where,
but I had to check into hotel flight got
delayed and I slept in this hotel room
that I swear like there must've been
something on the bed cause within a few
days like it was all,
you know,
it gets all nasty and cakey and then it
was eating a whole,
I wrote a whole blog post about this on
my website and they see,
you can see,
pull up the hole in the back of my leg.
It's nasty,
scares the shit out of him.
Just,
just search for like Ben Greenfield
staff and,
and you'll see the pictures.
But it was eating a whole in the back of
my leg and my,
my kids' role now,
once a week.
And I buy on,
I get the,
the defense soap from on it and as soon
as they come,
as soon as they come back in the door,
I'd,
I'd have them go into the shower
upstairs and defense and race down.
Yeah.
They sent a bunch of different wipes and
stuff for people that train in a place
that doesn't have a,
a shower.
Yeah.
You gotta be careful that end,
uh,
thieves essential oil.
Like it's like going to a whole bunch of
companies make this version of essential
oil called thieves.
It's like clove and roads named after
these thieves who apparently never got
clove cinnamon,
Eucalyptus,
which is really good for staff and
Rosemay.
It's actually named that there's like
the story of like these four thieves
that apparently traveled around the
world and they would rob Holmes and,
and uh,
and they never got sick.
Like that's basically the story.
I'm sure this was,
this was some board table at a,
at a multilevel marketing essential oils
company.
Somebody came up with this story or it
could be true.
I don't know.
But the um,
yeah,
the,
the stem cells into the Dick that,
that was an interesting one,
but it did.
Um,
I think from what I can tell,
looking in the mirror,
it got bigger.
I'm pretty,
how much?
So half inch.
Oh,
like maybe that much,
like enough to tell and my erections got
bigger and my orgasms got a lot better
for how long they,
they're still like that still.
Yeah.
So it fits.
So I think the stem cell,
it's kind of like stick with you.
Um,
well last week I got them,
I told you I'm training for the RKC
Kettlebell cert and I was doing the,
the hundred reps in five minutes snatch
test with a,
with a one and a half food.
And I felt something just go,
I was at 84 reps and I felt something go
in my back and I got stem cells injected
all up and down my ql,
my multifidus,
my rector spinae into my so ass.
But then they also sent them to me,
to my house and I did that same vat sell
the stuff that's rich and the
Mesenchymal stem cells into the
bloodstream.
So I did a push ivy into the
That's the one that you would have to go
out of the country to do a,
normally you're not supposed to do that.
Like that's tech.
It's technically not legal for someone
to inject you with your own stem cells
into your bloodstream.
But if you get your stem cells extracted
and they're stored and they send them to
you,
you can technically inject them.
If you do it yourself where you're like,
have a friend who's a nurse or whatever
and you,
it's literally just like a push ivy.
It was like 30 seconds.
We,
we caught it on video for a men's health
films,
so they'll publish a video at some
point.
But I was super nervous because it's
like a few thousand dollars worth of
stem cells that,
you know,
I'm,
I'm trying to hit the vein and make sure
that they go in the right way and
inject.
It's a very,
very small amount.
What you had to be the most nervous
getting them shut in your Dick though.
No,
I was kinda nervous.
Yeah.
That's super experimental.
I do a lot of that though.
I mean like that.
That's kind of my shtick.
Like I do a lot of immersive journalism,
a lot of self experimentation and a lot
of a lot of Guinea pig type stuff.
Uh,
and I'm,
I'm not dead yet and I still have my
deck so I,
you look great.
I'm happy.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Look very healthy.
I'm 22 I'm actually,
oh yeah,
that's,
is that,
yeah.
Is that,
that's one of them.
That is,
yeah.
That's an image from my website that's
not as deep as it got.
I don't think that's the worst photo.
The worst one I've ever seen.
He's Kevin randomness stuff it with
iodine.
Like they have you got a sore?
No,
they have like these long iodine strips
when you get the [inaudible] and it's
like it's flesh eating bacteria.
Yeah,
that's me too.
And they stuffed see that hole in the
middle.
They stuff like iodine.
It's like a stick in there,
like a strip that has,
but they literally stuffed it in there
and you can feel it.
You got,
you were telling me you got dry needling
done and you know like that weird
pressure.
It's not like pain,
but it's like a weird pressure from dry
needling.
This is like that except pain,
right?
Like it's both the pain and the PR.
It was horrible,
horrible.
Like I've had some falls and [inaudible]
staff in their leg where they have like
all small golf ball size holding their
leg and they literally had a packet full
of that kind of gauze covering.
I don't like how you say a small golf
golf balls,
a big hole for the back of the leg golf
ball,
but it's like smaller than a golf ball
or go large marble.
Any hole in the back of the leg.
And my opinion is too big I've ever
seen.
It's Kevin Randleman.
See if he could find Kevin randleman
staff.
He had open holes.
We could see his muscle structure under
his armpit.
It was horrific.
Gosh,
he would,
he never really recovered.
He was dying.
He died.
He died young from that.
Who knows what he died from.
But look at the whole,
I think I still have it.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
That's uh,
that's his muscle tissue around it.
What body part is that?
That's his underarm.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah.
That's how bad it was.
That looks like he got shot.
He does.
Yeah.
He was rotting away.
And I don't know if he didn't treat it
quickly enough or I don't know if it was
just really aggressive,
but it's a real common thing in gyms.
And then once you get it,
it stays with you.
Like it stays in your bloodstream.
Like I still,
like I have an essential oil diffuser on
my desk and I put thieves in it everyday
and I just diffuse essential oils in the
air while I'm working into the,
yeah,
it's like a nebulizing essential oil
diffuser and I just,
just,
just to play it safe.
Right.
I just want to be breathing that in one
day,
just in case.
Fuck.
That's,
um,
and that's the other thing is I stand in
front of this light,
this infrared light,
and this is that Dick Light.
Yes.
It's called a Jew.
And,
um,
so it,
they've,
they've done these studies on testicular
and sperm production and they've found
that there's a wavelength that's like
600 to 800 nanometers wavelength of
light that if you expose the testicles
to that for five to 20 minutes a day,
it's based on this concept of photo
biomodulation.
So I originally got into this whole
photo biomodulation thing when this
company,
cause I,
cause I blog and people just send me
these weird things to my doorstep to,
to try and they sent me this like nasal
probe that you put up your nose and it's
got like a helmet on it.
You could,
you could look it up Jamie,
if you want us,
call them,
uh,
via light.
And it produces this light that
supposedly activates a part of your
metrics.
So you have like your electron transport
chain in your Mitochondria and there's a
part of that called the cytochrome c
oxidase and it apparently activates more
activity in the cytochrome c oxidase to
produce more ATP in this case in neural
tissue.
Cause you have it on your head.
And they were using this in dementia and
in Alzheimer's patients.
But it turns out it's almost like a,
like a nootropic for your head.
Yes.
That's me at my desk back,
back when I was back when I was a young
Chinese woman,
my desk,
um,
up your nose on your head.
I like how that guy is just like looking
pensively it's cross rate of the well
and she's reading a book like he's
reading twilight.
That's what I originally did.
They sent me just the nose one and I
felt shorted because a,
they had like the full head.
So ask him for the full head one and
fucking weird and you can feel like
Holtz it.
And uh,
and uh,
what's the um,
it was I think it was MPR.
It was either radio lab or um,
let's see.
Other science when the end,
I think it think it might be radiolab.
They did a study on that or a,
or a story unlike this 10 to 40 hertz
frequency know,
talked about us.
That's tdcs oh nine volts trans
stimulation.
I have one of those to the Trans direct
cranial stimulation,
that halo device that you wear before a
workout and use that thing.
No one at a time,
one at a time.
So this photo biomodulation I'm putting
this thing,
you know the probe in my ear and you're
not even supposed to use it too much
because it produces so much atp that if
you amp up cellular activity in neural
tissue too much,
you produced too many reactive oxygen
species.
Like that's a byproduct of cellular
metabolism.
It's just like if you eat too much,
you produce a lot of byproduct of making
energy and that's why it's one of the
reasons why fasting is good for you.
Like it cleans up the system and you
don't make as many free radicals.
The same reason like Ketosis is good for
you,
right?
You're not burning as much glucose,
you don't produce as many free radicals.
Same concept with this.
You don't want to use it all the time
because you get too much activity.
You produce too many free radicals are
too many reactive oxygen species,
but every other day use it.
So New Year,
new you,
new Dick.
How often did you,
well,
this is from my head and I,
and this was like a couple of years ago,
same thing a couple of years,
and it was like a cup of coffee for my
brain.
Like every time I'd wake up,
I put this thing out when I'm working at
my desk.
So then,
um,
this company that makes these lights
that are very similar,
activate cytochrome c oxidase,
activates a release of nitric oxide.
But if you do it on your testicles,
specifically the cell that it works on
is the Leydig cells in the testes,
which are responsible for producing
testosterone.
So you're basically stimulating the
leydig cells in the testes the same way
that you'd stimulate like neural tissue
using this one for your head.
So I'd had success with the thing for my
head.
So I tried this one for the balls and
the Dick.
And what I did was I would just Jack my
pants down for five to 20 minutes a day
while I'm saying that,
what?
Yeah,
I'm diffusing my essential oils that I
got to pick on my head.
And,
um,
and it works like you actually get more
blood flow.
I mean,
I,
I didn't do a control study just pulling
my pants down and standing there for
five to 20 minutes south.
It without the light on.
I should,
I should do that at some point.
Cause maybe it's just like the whole,
you know,
it's like supposedly going combat style
is supposed to be good for your Dick to
combat style.
So there's you,
that's me balls out.
I'm standing on standing on my wobble
board.
I got my ball of light and um,
that's actually not my office.
I wasn't one of my friend's houses cause
he had one.
And uh,
anyways,
uh,
and um,
obviously I'm not naked,
but normally I would,
I would,
I would be nude and uh,
yeah.
And,
and you just basically new your balls.
Yeah.
And it's like a warm teddy bear.
Increased vascularity,
better size,
better orgasms.
I mean like,
like all this stuff.
It seemed to have a,
so all of this stuff seems to make your
day had some kind of where it had some
kind of an effect.
Yeah.
So,
um,
PRP injections,
acoustic sound wave therapy,
stem cells,
the infrared light,
a gas station,
Dick Pills.
And that's the one I would not repeat.
Um,
and then they had me do some ayurvedic
stuff,
like the no ejaculation thing.
We just kind of like where,
where Tantra have sex.
But you pull out the river like the uh,
it's a book,
it's called the the multiorgasmic men.
So I read that and learned how to like,
you know,
pull back,
like,
like not actually orgasm and you're like
pull it inside and then you finish up
and you're just like pissed off the rest
of the day.
He tell he can't sleep at night because
you're all,
you're just thought why?
So you could see how it would work.
But for me it's like I got kids and my
wife and I sneak away to get it on.
Like I wanna I want,
I want the full meal deal.
So I didn't like that.
The,
the no ejaculate reverse orgasm thing.
But it's supposed to do like when you
internalize the orgasm,
when you keep it inside.
So this is all based on Chinese medicine
principles.
Like your,
I think it's called your gin or your
Djing or something like that,
but
you have this,
this energy,
you know,
your,
your ci or your Pronto,
your Chakra,
your life force.
And apparently orgasming is an in and
coming like ejaculating is supposedly
one of the ways that you give some of
that life force away.
Like you release some of your vitality
and by having sex but then not coming,
you're actually creating that same
hormonal response of oxytocin and
testosterone and all these things that
we release when we're having sex.
One way ejaculate,
but without actually giving up that,
that vitality,
that life force there was even like I
found,
I found like a tables were like based on
your age,
there's a certain frequency with which
you're supposed to ejaculate.
Like,
like the younger you are,
it's like every two days,
every three days.
And the older you get,
like it gets to a certain point where
you're like 70 years old and it's like
every,
every month or something like that.
And so it's,
it's,
it's kind of interesting.
But again,
I don't,
I don't like that.
Like I want,
I want,
I want to finish.
But again,
preconceived prejudice that you have
though.
Like a wonder if you just went into it
like completely objectively would have
some sort of a benefit.
Uh,
or maybe you'd just get like mineral
depleted and you lose all your zinc and
everything else you need to make sperm
and you'll start to cramp up.
I Dunno.
To me,
you'd have to be ejaculate in a lot,
I think.
So when you were doing all these
different things,
how much of a time,
like how much of a buffer did you give
yourself in between each thing?
So it was not a well controlled
experiment at all.
It was like three months.
It's just like,
Hey,
do that.
why don't we try this?
Let's say,
hey,
the articles coming out soon,
we should toss this in there too.
So they probably compounded,
it was not a well controlled experiment
and I did a lot over three months.
Like it would have been a lot better and
just try one thing at a time.
But I,
but I,
but I am well hung and very vascular
now.
Credulous will experiment.
So,
so there's that.
Um,
so yeah,
it's called New Year,
so new year,
new deck.
And it really did make your Dick Bigger.
So do you think there's any help out
hope out there?
Asking for a friend,
guys who have microdex micro,
what's a micro Dick [inaudible] small
penis.
I would imagine there's whole pantry.
They could be like great politicians or
influential and that there's gotta be
some kind of trade off,
right?
Like if you,
if you have sickle cell anemia,
apparently it keep protected from
malaria.
So maybe if you have a small Dick,
it protects you from some kind of
horrible accident later on in lighting.
So I don't think so.
I just wonder like,
if there's a way to fix that and people,
if maybe this was the way it was.
I've always felt like that's gotta be
one of the saddest things yet.
Um,
again,
like you never know.
There could be a bunch of nine year old
man walking around with Dick Cancer 60
years from now who heard this?
And I went and got injected.
So I will not attest to the safety of
it,
but kind of test the efficacy of it.
Um,
so some of those things would work for
that.
For All those people walking around
there.
All of your listeners have small dicks
gave them salvation.
There's old fellows.
There's hope.
So.
So yeah.
That's um,
is that like you're,
you're saying it's still works.
Like it's,
how long ago did you do this experiment?
Oh,
I mean like the,
the magazine is still on the shelves.
Like it just kept going.
He said,
how long is it was like [inaudible] was
like starting,
I got the stem cells extracted in August
of 2017 so this is like the end of
January,
eight weeks later I got those shot into
the deck and we only made a couple of
weeks,
months later after they really grow in a
lot of these Mesenchymal mesenchymal
stem cells.
I got them injected into my bloodstream
and in the like that injury that I'm
fighting in my back right now.
Um,
and I'd done some other things before
that for,
for the backend,
for tissue like peptides like this,
uh,
the bpc one 57 that we were just talking
about before.
Yeah.
Which is really interesting stuff.
I mean,
it's not,
it's not intended for human consumption,
but it's also not banned by water.
I mean it's,
it's,
it actually it's legal to use and it's a
peptide.
Um,
it's called body protection compound bpc
one 57,
and the one 57 refers to like the
sequence of amino acids that makes up
the actual compound.
But you can buy it and reconstitute it.
And then if you inject it into an area,
and it doesn't even have to be like a
painful intramuscular injection,
it can be like a subcutaneous injection.
BPC supposedly stimulates angiogenesis
and it's an,
it's a natural compound.
You find it in the human gut.
So they took this same thing that helps
to heal the human gut,
which is why if you were to consume this
and drinking water,
it supposedly,
and this is an in rodent models,
it apparently works to like heal up an
inflamed gut,
Colitis,
ibd,
ibs,
stuff like that.
But you can inject it into a joint or
subcutaneously into an area around the
joint.
And it's supposedly stimulates the,
uh,
I feel like this is a repetitive phrase
on this show.
The growth of new blood vessels.
So angio,
angiogenesis,
and then there's another one called tb
500 that they use in race horses,
the thymus in Beta.
That one is banned by water,
but same similar principle except that
one acts on the actin and myocin fibers
and actually causes regeneration of
those.
So you could do both and he get
angiogenesis and then also fiber
regrowth.
And that,
that's,
that's a strategy that would be like
pennies on the dollar compared to stem
cells.
And also,
you know,
a far less,
I'm far less intensive procedure in
terms of collecting your stem cells.
Right?
Yeah.
And then there's,
um,
so there's,
there's a fat for the stem cells and
from what I understand,
if you're going after the anti aging
effect,
like the bone is better like the mirror,
like a bone marrow.
So I had mine,
I had my bone marrow extracted at this
place called forever labs in Berkeley,
California.
And they store that.
And then what I can do is I can just
inject the 35 year old me into my body
every year or every five years or
whenever I want to put that back in.
So I've got bone marrow and fat marrow
stored.
So they take the bone marrow and how do
they have enough to just keep going?
Do they replicate it?
I don't know.
The protocol that used to grow this
stuff,
like I know the fat one,
they use like a collagenase procedure
that enzymatically breaks down the
college and from the fat and somehow
concentrates the stem cells and you can
actually grow them.
Like you can actually multiply them.
I'm assuming it's something similar for
bone and the bone would be more for like
longevity and anti aging and in the fat
would be more for for joints.
I know a lot of people got the bone
marrow done for injuries.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And it's supposed to be too painful.
Was it painful for you and they
extracted the bone?
Not compared to the Dick injections.
It's all relative.
But I,
I'm,
I've been,
I've been obstacle course racing and
that was,
I was triathlete before that and did
body build.
So I've always done all this masochistic
shit.
So getting,
I think my pain tolerance is,
is,
hi Don.
Uh,
the,
the bone marrow,
it didn't hurt that much.
No,
it was that day.
They numb it.
They go in.
Um,
the Dick one was where there was like
that weird pressure.
A little bit of pain.
I would say that the iodine packing into
the staph infection that you're talking
about,
that was,
that was up there.
Daniel Cormier,
Yang Ufc light heavyweight champion,
had it done with the bone marrow and he
was telling me it was painful as hell
and he's about as tough name getting
a's.
I checked it again and just hanging out.
So I mean it's,
it's a big needle.
It was limping around.
He said for awhile when I did the stem
cell injections,
that was cool cause they used,
they used a digital thermography.
She can,
it's like an ultrasound.
It's like what you would use to look at
a baby.
Yeah.
But you can't,
you can see the tissue,
you can see the areas where there's
swelling or there's like a black area
where,
where the tissue is torn up or whether
there's a Dema or inflammation and you
can and,
and um,
uh,
he showed me the video after he did all
the injections.
You can see the needle like going into
the,
you can,
you can micro target exactly.
Exactly where you want to put the cells.
Yeah,
I've done it.
Very,
very cool procedure.
Don't want to use that.
Cool.
Thermography.
Yeah.
It's a cool procedure.
Have you ever done Regena keen?
No.
You're aware of it.
You know what it is.
It's a,
it's one of the things that a lot of pro
athletes are going to Germany to get
done.
It's a,
it's a form of platelet rich plasma
where the heat it up and by heating up
the,
uh,
the plasma,
it produces this radical
anti-inflammatory property.
It's like they extract it into this
yellow serum.
They spin it in a centrifuge.
So if you're going to get it done,
I've had it done on how is that
different than just normal prp?
More powerful.
More poorly because it's it up.
Yeah.
Cause some PRP before.
I have as well.
Yeah.
It's,
I mean,
obviously I'm not doctor,
but,
uh,
according to these doctors that do it,
and there's a place in Santa Monica that
does it called lifespan medicine.
I've had it done really for the longest
time.
You had to go to Germany,
like Dana white flew to Germany to get
it done because it was illegal.
They hadn't,
yeah,
they had an interest,
but can go on a,
I'm going over to,
uh,
to,
Venice beach.
I'm going to be done by there.
I'm going to these cats.
The uh,
that place I was talking about the human
garage.
That's an interesting place.
I really want to talk to the guy who
does it.
My friend Doctor Ben [inaudible],
he is the guy who performed the
procedures down there.
He's a great guy.
He would love to talk to you too.
Yeah,
sure.
Cool.
You'd get a kick out of it.
It's pretty interesting.
Some day I'll run out of stuff so you
inject it into joints,
but for now,
for me it really helped me heal a
bulging disc in my neck.
Rarely they go right into the spinal
cord.
It's great for people that have pretty
serious neck injuries and back injuries.
Have you tried this thing?
I think it's,
it's pet AECON is a company that makes
it,
but it's like a neck traction device.
I have one hanging him that in a yoga
trapeze and so all your hands and you're
all hanging by the neck.
I do this when I get up,
I get up and I put like a bunch of
magnesium on my neck and my back to
relax all the tissue.
And once you get really relaxed and have
this,
uh,
this vibrator,
it's a,
it's like a car buffer for your body so
you can vibrate your neck and your back
and then you get really,
really relaxed and it's perfect for,
you know,
for like doing your own deep tissue
therapy but it,
but it vibrate.
So I'll do that on my body and I go hang
from this neck thing and you get all of
these pops up and down in your neck.
And I,
and it apparently realigns the atlas and
the axis and some of the cervical
vertebra and there's probably a bunch of
chiropractic docs who are,
who are,
uh,
really,
pissed off right now because I'm
describing this incorrectly.
But it,
it feels amazing.
Like it just adjusts everything.
And then I hang from the yoga trapeze
and,
but when it definitely seems like five
minutes.
Yeah,
definitely.
Decompresses your,
I don't know about all that other
nonsense,
but it definitely,
it's stretching out those muscles and
alleviating some of the stress that
comes from bad posture.
And for me it was a lot of grappling
getting your neck cranked and squished
and resisting thing.
It's like,
um,
it's kinda similar to traction and I
really been getting into that.
Have you heard of [inaudible]?
it's like a form of stretching where I
actually had a guy come to my house for
two days and he stayed in my basement.
And the way we wake up,
I've done this a few times,
we'll have people come over to me and
just like teach it.
There's,
there's another guy who mashes it like
use a walker and just like mash up and
down your body.
And uh,
but this is El Della,
so l Doa,
you'll like push a joint out this way
and then out this way and then your feet
will be splayed in both directions.
There's like 20 different poses that you
do,
but it's a form of self traction.
Right.
So it's like,
um,
it's similar to like if you were to use
a monster band to traction a join,
have you ever done that?
Like traction,
you're hip with a real tie,
a monster band around your hip and then
attach it to I have not potassium and
joint apart.
Yeah.
That's all Doa.
Is that Adam from mine pump that is that
the mind pump that he,
and I think that's my buddy Adam.
It says spinal health l.
Dot.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
So that,
that's one of the ones I do in the
morning.
And that's l five s one so that,
so they all work on a specific,
like part of the back,
the part of the body,
let me say it again.
Eld [inaudible] l five or l five,
I forget what it stands for.
It was invented by this guy named
[inaudible].
Yay.
A French guy.
And uh,
dude,
you feel amazing.
You,
you hold these poses for like a minute
and it introduces a bunch of new blood
flow to the joint.
They see how he's doing that.
He'll like put his hand up and traction
the Fascia.
And so he's getting this intense poll.
If you're to do this,
you get this intense poll on your back.
I do this one cause I get it.
I could show it to you after,
but you feel amazing.
I do this when I wake up now and uh,
who knitted this vertical farming
stressing this goes back.
This is like some,
some French guy invented it and uh,
I don't remember how I heard about it
but,
or I uh,
uh,
interview this guy named Jacob Shawn on
my podcast and he taught me all these
moves and getting my house and uh,
it's,
it's another one of those really cool
forms of stretching.
It's like you do yoga.
I have a,
uh,
of a sauna.
You Do,
you have do like an infrared sauna.
We have a regular sauna.
I use,
uh,
like,
like a near far infrared sauna.
And I go in there,
cause you're,
your tissue gets very pliable and hot.
So I had a,
I had a crane drop a 19 foot and endless
pool out in the forest back behind my
house.
And I keep this thing just like super
duper cold,
right?
So it's like 45,
50 degrees.
So that's like my,
my cryotherapy cold water immersion.
Well during the,
during the winter and the fall just
stays that cold.
I just keep the lid off.
And then during the summer when I'm
coming back home and I'm going by the
gas station up the up the hill before my
house,
I stopped and I buy ice bags and I just
dumped them in there.
So it's so it stays relatively cold.
And uh,
what I do in the mornings when I'm home,
as I do this sauna and you asked about
yoga,
I go in there and this is when I do a
lot of this stuff,
right?
Like I'll do some of my yoga moves,
some of my elders.
There was another really good form of
stretching called core foundation,
uh,
doc named Eric Goodman.
And it's like a form of decompression
for the spine.
And he works with a lot of athletes,
kind of like turns on your glutes
decompresses your spine.
So I,
I just use a mash up of all these little
moves and I'll be in my sauna for like
30 minutes.
So I'm producing all the,
all the heat shock proteins.
I'm getting the nitric oxide,
get in the blood flow and you just feel,
you feel good.
We did a sauna,
so I get all sweaty and I get kind of,
we will sprinkle essential oils in there
and I'll burn like Palo Santo incense
and you know,
put on burn incense inside the song
feeds.
Yeah,
it smells really nice.
And again,
it's like,
yeah,
like binaural beats.
So there's this,
this guy named,
um,
Michael Tyrrell,
and he makes these,
these cds and these tracks that you said
his name,
you load your vote.
When Michael Tyrrell retirees,
he's amazing tracks and they're,
uh,
they,
they vibrate at specific hertz
frequencies right there.
So there's this whole idea that like
your root Chakra,
like your fourth chalky,
your heart shock or vibrates it 528
hertz.
And there's,
there's different hertz frequencies
associated with different positive
aspects of,
of euro.
You know,
it's this,
uh,
it's like,
a Chakra like oh shit.
I mean,
have you tried to debunk any of that?
I feel really good.
I'm trying to,
good.
If I feel good,
I'm going to try to be deep us to do it.
Yeah.
My notes.
Are you doing this with headsets on?
No,
that song it has like surround speakers
and so I just,
I play that through the speakers.
No Bluetooth and no Wifi.
Jay May just like,
it's just like my little shitty little
ipod shuffle that I plug it and play.
And um,
so I play that while I'm in the sauna
and I'm doing all my moves and then I
walk out of my house,
go through my office,
walked through the forest and I go and
jump in the pool and swim in there for
like fights,
like 50 yards.
It's not jumped the other one to the
other and no,
it's too much to go back and forth.
Like I've tried to just,
I got to keep things somewhat cause this
is getting kind of complex between like
the light in the balls and the essential
oils.
Like you gotta you gotta draw the line
somewhere ourselves.
Sometimes I'll have friends over and,
and we'll vapor will smoke in the sauna
and then we'll go out to the pool and
then go roll around in the snow.
They get back in the pool and go back in
the sauna.
And My,
I do this and my wife is inside making
dinner and we just feel amazing.
I,
we got the hot,
we got the cold and then we'd go in and
we eat dinner and it's,
it's amazing.
It's my favorite thing to do with my
friends.
Wow.
But in the morning and do the sauna and
the ice and then or there or the cold
pool.
And then I finished with a quick dip in
the hot tub out in the trees cause I put
a hot tub next to the cold pool and
everything's like super clean.
You know,
it's cleaned with ozone and minerals
instead of chlorine.
And so you just feel really,
really clean.
And I walk in and start my day.
I feel like wow.
Blocks.
So I do yoga.
Yeah.
But it's in the,
it's in the song.
Well,
it sounds like you're just stretching,
you know,
doing like the strengthening I do actual
like,
well what do you mean like standing
boyer one warrior two or three like like
standing bow pose,
head to knee pose.
I do strenuous doing like old person
yoga.
I do that legit shit.
I'm not in a questioning.
I do a headstand.
I'm just wondering what you're doing
actually in the sauna.
Yeah,
I'd make it up as I go.
I don't have like,
um,
I was just based on how you feel while I
was speaking in,
in code.
That's why I'm down here and speak in
Costa Mesa and a couple of days ago and
there was like this,
this banquet dinner as part of the event
and I'll sit next to this guy.
I'm like,
well what do you do for your fitness
routine?
Et cetera.
He does Bikram Yoga every day,
but like the Bikram Yoga,
like all of the poses that are part of
bigger meal because it's a set series of
routines.
You've done bikram before?
Yeah,
he has like 90 minutes and he does that
every single day at nine days in a row.
Yeah.
No,
he's been doing it for like years every
day.
I'm impressed.
Cause we did it.
We did sober October,
we had to do 15 about a month mean a
bunch of my friends.
Yeah.
I wanted to burn it out.
So the last nine days,
well I had a few days to go but for nine
days I just said let me just get these
out of the way.
And Yeah,
every day I did 90 minutes and it was
like wow.
But it's interesting because you realize
that your body can do that.
I don't like to Overdo it though because
it's static stretching.
We know that that can decrease forced
potential.
Like it can decrease power production
for the calm too pliable,
flexible.
Isn't that the case though?
Preworkout like well the workout,
but chronically,
if you elongate tissue,
and I don't know if they've actually
done any studies on people who have done
yoga for a really long time and compared
like their,
their vertical jump right before and
after.
But I just feel almost too stretchy if I
get too into it.
Like I feel like when I run it's a
little bit more like gumby running
versus limiting the amount of here.
That's interesting.
That's definitely,
definitely static stretching prior to
force production is not a good idea.
Right.
Like prior to things like squats or
something like that.
It was like when the,
when the lights went out during the
superbowl a few years ago,
you remember that.
And you could see on TV,
both teams were just like standing on
the sidelines or setting on the silent
doing these long hamstrings,
static stretches and Anne and I wondered
why they were doing it because they were
about to get back in and,
and engage in a very powerful explosive
sport.
So yeah,
it's,
it's a dynamic stretching.
Definitely price prior to force
production activities.
Yeah.
I wonder why they're doing,
maybe they just have really old school
trainers or something like that are not
aware or maybe they just doing it on our
own before I do that isometric training.
Um,
for,
for power production,
I've got two things.
I bought this stuff called them those
torque on Amazon.
You heard this stuff's towards like
smelling salts on steroids.
No,
power lifter told me about it and he
would sniff it before he'll go like,
you know,
rip a 700 pound bar off the ground and
you,
you snort that,
you open up the cap on this stuff and
it's just like releasing a wild animal
into the room and it released the cap.
It's like smelling salts on steroids and
you smell and you just want to go kill
somebody or find somebody.
Yeah.
It's called nose,
nose torque or knows Turk toward however
it's something like that.
Like no knows torque.
Yeah.
Tork Tork yeah,
there you go.
And so I do that.
And then the other one that I just made
as you can buy this for like pennies on
the dollar on Amazon.
Yeah.
You can get these essential oil
inhalers.
So there's some guy just smelled it.
Here we go.
Yeah.
Oh he can't even get it near his face.
He's got it.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's,
it's hard like gift packs of Bud.
Did he just do it or is he getting ready
to do it?
It's opened it up.
It's like smelling.
So it's ammonia.
So,
uh,
I don't know chemically like I would
imagine it just put your sympathetic
nervous system into overdrive when you
sniff all that ammonia.
[inaudible] he's been really ginger.
He's like,
Oh,
I've got to get some of my friends at
restaurants.
I carried around some times.
Jesus going into a restaurant.
I have smelt my bouquets.
Actually.
You could smell it.
Go get it.
Um,
right now you want to,
you want to sniff it right now?
All right,
let's do it.
Alright.
Knows torque.
It's out in the car.
I was in the car.
It's an,
you know what we'll do,
we'll do it after.
It'd be boring.
Podcasting.
Plus if people weren't really want to
try it,
they can just buy it on Amazon.
Um,
the other one is up and excites you and
allows you to,
so they should be on the field doing
that before they,
uh,
I don't know if I would recommend that.
You're probably seeing guys like
nosebleeds and heart attacks.
They,
um,
the other one is a peppermint.
Have you ever used like peppermint oil
in it?
And they've done studies on this,
on peppermint oil and athletic
performance.
And what I have is this little,
uh,
it,
it looks like a little Tampon or you can
buy these on Amazon.
They're called aroma therapy inhalers
and it's like this little cotton wick
and you put it,
you put essential oil on the cotton
wick,
right?
So it absorbs into the wic and then you
put the cap on and you can carry this
around in the gym in your pocket.
Or I played tennis on Wednesday night,
so I bring it to my tennis matches and
while I'm playing tennis,
I'll stop sometimes and sniff this
thing.
Kind of say like awake and alert and do
it like it is just peppermint,
just peppermint.
But it has this amazing effect.
It's like this wakefulness promoting
effects.
Peppermint.
Peppermint is amazing.
I put like if you get bloating or gas,
you can smear that around your,
your stomach and it makes it go away.
It goes one of my favorite oils to use.
Yeah.
How it gets absorbed through the skin.
I mean,
you know,
this is skin is skin is a out,
but a lot of the internal organs,
I don't know if it actually goes into
the actual stomach like in like like
through the,
through the epithelial lining and into
the end of the actual intestine.
But like it,
it has an effect for sure.
In terms of what I just started using
recently is topical cbd,
Topical Cbd and the lack a role on
almost like a deal on rent roll on kind
of a thing.
It's amazing.
The CBD,
there's a,
there's one,
um,
I used this stuff called bio cbd and
it's Tumeric or curcumin with CVD and
and yeah,
it's same thing.
It's like a topical,
they also do a thc like thc roll-ons
yeah,
they do that.
Another thing,
speaking of the,
of the sexual performance thing,
you can actually buy like thc,
sex lube and I mean it's like a high for
your crotch.
Literally.
You apply it locally and it's like your
crotch gets a high and you can do,
you can do the same thing with these
little uh,
coconut oil.
THC suppository,
while they're not suppository,
their demand for swallowing in the
mouth.
That's a normal route of delivery,
but you can shove them up your butt like
30 or 40 minutes before you have sex and
you actually get like this amazing high
for your crotch.
I was just like these thc coconut oil
capsules.
I just find out about that.
Just
put it up there.
The actual path salts,
not bath salts like the drug,
but the stuff that you put in the bath
now that's thc.
Really?
Yeah.
They're doing everything out here now.
It's crazy.
They've gotten hogwild because out here
like California,
Washington,
Washington's liberal.
But I'm the guy that I get my stuff from
in California.
It just started giving me this stuff to
put in the bath.
Yeah.
And he just,
he's like,
you gotta be careful though because
yeah.
Way Too high in your bag.
I believe it is with skin absorption.
Yeah.
You're literally like,
just like bathing in it like people bay
than in wine and these fancy spas.
Yeah.
What they bathed in wine.
You have wine bags?
Yeah.
There's this place I go to in New York
City.
Uh,
it's called Ra spot,
a IRA and they had like one of the
options to go there.
You can just take a bath and one that
sounds so like calligraphy,
the wine and a few versions and some
feed,
make grades.
She's taking a drip of this bow is wide.
Oh,
that's so strange.
It's kind of cheesy though.
She she looks like a news anchor.
Like yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
This is like for,
yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Grapes and there we go.
I called it the grapes.
You could say yeah,
that it's actually a cool spa.
I've never done the wine,
but it sounds,
why,
I don't know if you'd get drunk from the
wine.
I don't know if it would actually wind
up in your,
in your set,
but they use antioxidant rich temper neo
grapes.
Well how could you not get some sort of
absorption?
I'm sure you would get something about
the sensory deprivation tank is that
through the epsom salts,
your body absorbs a lot of magnesium.
Right?
I like the magnesium chloride,
like using actual magnesium and said,
and I like that cause you can get it
for,
I mean that's what they used to melt
ice.
Like you can just buy this stuff like
rocks hall.
I know you guys don't melt a lot of ice
in California,
but like in Washington state you can buy
magnesium chloride about like a fricking
like concrete size bag,
know concrete mixed size bag of it.
And it's the same stuff that they sell
on these expensive websites as like
magnesium salts.
It's just magnesium chloride and you can
dump that into your year,
way more magnesium than you get from
epsom salts.
Well that's really what you want is the
magnesium.
Like that's displacing the calcium.
That's pretty soon the relaxing effect
that's,
you know,
it's,
maybe I should add that to my tank
magnesium because I've already got
themselves first to make sure it's not
going to mess up the,
is there like a filtration mechanism on
the 10 yeah,
there's some pretty heavy filtration
system,
but it filters out the epson salts have
an idea for float tanks.
You know her my idea of course,
because that's where I just get it.
I get really bored and float tanks.
So yeah,
I just said,
and I,
uh,
no,
that's the mail going to the edibles.
You went out before.
I've only done it three times every time
in Austin,
Texas.
And it's always been like I've been on a
wife.
Yeah.
Charlie with a lot of people do with
ketamine don't die.
That's the,
um,
the guy who invented it.
John Lilly's method.
Yeah.
I have an edible that I make at home,
uh,
with,
with Kratom,
which is an opioid painkiller that's
freaking amazing.
It induces this euphoria like,
hi,
and then I add CBD Thc,
Copaiba Oil,
if you've heard of this.
No.
Copaiba oil acts on the endocannabinoid
receptors very similarly to thc and cbd,
but it has what's called like an
entourage effect,
meaning it enhances the effects of CBD
and thc.
So like if you're,
if you're vaping,
you can add like a couple of drops of
oil over the top of the herbs,
um,
or you can mix it into like an edible
cakes that you make.
Yeah,
I saw.
Amazing.
Wow.
My sister accidentally took one last
week and said she had the best night of
sleep of her life.
Really?
And uh,
I don't travel with them cause they just
smell like you just open up a,
a what?
Bass can full of weed.
So it's,
you know what,
you don't want those in the bouquets
when you're traveling dogs.
Yeah,
exactly.
Every time I pull line of dogs,
follow me through the airport.
We're like Oj Simpson.
Anyways though,
the um,
the,
the uh,
mix.
I use coconut oil and g and dark
chocolate and a little bit of Stevia.
Like I have this butterscotch toffees
Stevia.
It's amazing.
I travel everywhere.
I put it in sparkling water.
I put it in coffee.
It's like an organic butter,
Scotch toffee,
Stevia addicted to it.
It's a,
it's a company called,
oh,
Micah organics.
I actually get it.
I get a three pack.
O,
m I c a I get off Amazon is,
was vanilla butterscotch toffee and
plane.
Like if you just don't want,
if you want to sweeten something but you
don't want those extra flavors,
best best dba.
So I put all this in the edible and I
have this countertop immersion blender
called the,
uh,
a magical butter machine.
And you,
you blend this and it blends on top of
your counter for like eight hours and
all this stuff that makes us together.
And then you pour it into molds and you
can just put it in the,
in the freezer.
And then I keep it in these like little
Miron glass jars so it doesn't degrade
and it's just like the best,
best edible.
So I should try something before float
tanks.
Yeah.
Returned to my float tank idea.
Okay.
So I get these ideas when I'm in the
float tank and I want to,
and usually it's like five or 10 minutes
in.
So I spend the next 50 minutes trying to
remit like,
don't forget this,
don't forget it.
And I try to like these little mnemonic
techniques where you imagine like,
Eh,
you know,
the,
like an image of what you remembered is
waiting for you outside the door as soon
as you opened the float tank.
So it,
it might work for you to remember and,
but basically it just kind of screws up
my whole ability to be able to just like
let thoughts come and go and relax.
So my idea is this,
why not have some kind of a recorder
going forward or you thought we made a
record and you can get those shit?
I was the first one to the wall.
No,
screw it.
I've been doing,
okay,
so,
so like a voice activated recording.
Yeah.
Do you have one like I never did
because,
and then you walk out and you just get
an MP three play buck.
Yeah.
Thought of.
I,
I've been trying to figure out what a
good one would be and how to set it up
in there with all the salts and not have
it degrade.
But I think you could figure it out.
I mean my thoughts are,
I thought is a Velcro,
velcro patch.
Slap it in when you go in there and then
activate it.
You ever see those voice activated ones
with a red light and seeing voice
activated recorders?
Yeah.
I don't want to break the lie.
You super easy.
Yeah.
Well they make these led.
Um,
uh,
you know,
they're,
they're like,
uh,
you know,
cause I,
when I travel I don't like to get all
the blue light and the hotel rooms and
I'll unplug things.
Try to make the hotel room dark.
Right?
Cause when you flip off the lights in a
hotel room,
it's just like fricking Vegas,
right?
There's blue lights on the TV and stuff
flashing all over the place.
So they make these,
and I had it for awhile.
I don't travel with it any more,
but it's like a black tape you can put
over over things that light up in a
room.
You're,
you,
something like that.
It's like,
uh,
you can,
they're like led light blockers.
It's like tape basically,
but you just put it over the cover of
anything that lights up.
You can use something like that on the
digital recorder.
Wow.
Get to sell this for millions of
dollars.
Well I think the digital recorded thing
is a really good idea and someone needs
to,
I need to think,
and I have my idea.
It was not your idea.
I thought at first,
when did you first start doing it all?
I thought it was like two years ago and
they had one of them.
I've had a tank since 2002 early.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I agree.
I raced an ironman triathlon for eight
years and just got tons of sensory dep
in the water.
Just staring at that black line at the
bottom of the pool.
It's hard for me to just like get in
water and relax and not feel like you
have to swim or I just,
I've never been able to get that
relaxed.
No,
that's interesting.
So you associate like water with the
movement because associate water with
swimming.
I like,
I get in water and I won it and I love
water,
right.
Like I,
I free dive and I spear fish.
I read this book,
um,
deep by James Nest Door,
amazing book about all these cool things
that going when you go down deep and he
talks about how Olympic athletes are
using this now to enhance the
performance because your spleen
compresses and you produce more
renewable,
eaten more red blood cells.
Same thing that you produced.
Actually,
if you,
if you sauna,
like if you do a workout and you get
really hot and then you go in the sauna
after they've done studies on this and
they found that 30 minutes of heat
therapy after you've already gotten the
body hot,
you produce hipo the same as if you were
to use the performance enhancing drug.
It's like,
that's interesting because there was a
statistic just came out about
cryotherapy and this is this echo
something that Rhonda Patrick was saying
that if you do Cryo,
her advice was you should wait at least
an hour after a workout before you do it
and allow your body to have some sort of
effect,
uh,
from,
from the exercise.
But Sauna,
they're saying you should do almost
immediately after.
So the,
the idea with this,
and there was a brand new study that
just came out like three days ago where
they showed that heat post exercise
enhanced the effects of exercise,
whereas cold blunted the hormetic
response to exercise,
which makes sense.
It's the same thing side of a window
though.
It's a window of time.
So,
so the deal is you don't want to blunt
the hermetic response.
Sexualized high dose antioxidants,
cryotherapy,
cold immersion,
all of that can do this.
That's a problem with but fighters cause
a lot of fighters are getting into cold
immersion like immediately afterwards.
Exactly what you'd want to wait until
later on in the day.
There's no research on the amount of
time.
For me what I do it same thing when I do
like a hard afternoon and work out a way
to couple hours afterwards cause you get
a bigger testosterone and growth hormone
response when you wait after work out to
eat.
I was uh,
actually actually mark Sisson was the
first guy who told me about this and it
turns out that there actually is a
better hormonal response when you fast
post exercise.
Same thing with antioxidants and there
were a couple of exceptions I can tell
you about.
Same thing with a cryotherapy,
not the same time.
If you finish up a hard afternoon or
especially like an early evening
workout,
you have a very high body temperature.
So my theory is that a brief dose of
cold,
like all jump in the cold pool and get
out and not if not a phone call,
just enough to decrease the core body
temperature,
which is one of the ways that you
enhanced deep sleep cycles.
So I also sleep on this thing called the
chilly pad that circulates like cold
water underneath my body wirelessly
start sent me one of those things.
And the cool thing is like your partner
can put their temperature on and I can
put my temperature on and you can,
you can sleep or whatever temp you want.
So I sleep with this thing as cooking
oil at 55 degrees.
Yeah,
but it's not,
it's like background noise cause I sleep
with all these binaries and everything.
Anyway.
I use the strict codes called sleep
stream.
It's like a Dj for sleep.
So I put my phone in airplane mode and
then I have these,
these noise blocking headphones.
And if you're a side sleeper,
you can use these things called sleep
phones,
which is like a headband that goes
around your head.
Um,
anyways though back to the,
to the not doing the cold after
exercise.
So you wait a little while.
But I think decreasing the body's core
temperature is good.
So like a cold shower,
cold water immersion also beats out
crowd therapy because yeah,
it's actually more.
And there was a study they did last
month on this,
that cold water immersion was very
effective in reducing postworkout muscle
soreness and that inflammatory response
to exercise compared to cryotherapy.
But again,
you should wait a little bit before you
do it each way a little bit before you
do it.
But I think part of that is due to you
get like this hydrostatic pressure of
water against the skin,
right?
So it kind of pushes the cold against
the skin a little bit better.
Uh,
and then the other reason is that when
your head gets wet,
when you're head goes under,
you know,
same thing as you would get with a cold
shower.
You get like this Mammalian dive reflex,
right?
Like that sharp intake of breath and
that activates your vagus nerve.
So we talked about HRV and heart rate
variability tracking.
Anytime you do something like that that
improves the tone of the Vegas nerve,
you would actually improve your ability
to recover and improve the strength of
your,
of your nervous system.
And they sell like vagal nerve
stimulators and they've looked into like
chanting humming a singing,
uh,
jaw,
they call it jaw realignment therapy
apparently removes the pressure that the
trigeminal nerve can place on the vegas
nerve.
There's all these things you can do to
enhance the health of the vegas nerve
and that's one of the things that
improve your hrv or your heart rate
variability allows your sympathetic and
your parasympathetic nervous system
tone.
Like what do you mean by that?
The tone of the nerve?
Uh,
it would basically be synonymous with
like the,
the health of the nerve.
I don't know what,
what's actually,
I don't know if it's,
if it's changing like the,
uh,
you know,
what,
what do you call them?
The myelin sheath of the nerve or
something like that.
When,
when you're increasing the tone of the
nerve,
but more or less,
it's healthy for the vegas nerve when
you get,
when you get your head wet or
underwater.
So when I go in my cold pool,
after workout,
I put my head under and then come up
like five or 10 times just to go up and
down and up and down.
Then I get out and if I'm going to do a
longer cold soak,
it's not right after a workout.
The,
um,
the two studies I found on antioxidant
use after workout,
right?
High dose antioxidants like vitamin C,
vitamin E,
et Cetera,
that's supposedly blunts the hermetic
response to exercise.
But there was one study that shows that
green tea polyphenols don't do that.
So green tea would allow you to fight
off the inflammatory effects of exercise
without blunting.
For example,
satellite cell proliferation or of new
Mitochondria are all of the things that
you want to happen.
And the other one was a,
and this is,
this is a new thing,
like not a lot of people are talking
about this now,
but it's like hydrogen rich compounds.
Like,
they call it hydrogen rich water.
And there's these companies now,
there's like four or five of them.
They sell like these tablets that you
can dissolve in water and there's a,
uh,
the molecular hydrogen foundation,
they do research on,
on this hydrogen and they're not,
they don't have a financial affiliation
with any of these companies.
So I respect some of the research that
they do and they've found that it
actually blunts the,
or it allows for antiinflammatory and
antioxidant effects to shut down,
like the inflammatory response to
exercise without blunting the hormetic
response.
So it'd be like green tea and molecular
hydrogen would be the two things that I
know of that you could do postworkout to
blunt that inflammatory response without
actually,
um,
blunting the hormetic response to
exercise so it'll enhance without
exactly.
Exactly.
Have your cake and eat it too.
One of the things that I think that's
probably really good about cold
immersion therapy also,
I think there's a meditative aspect of
getting into that incredible cold and
just relaxing and calming.
And I think it does something for your
mind.
It does.
And it's the nervous system right?
Like what I tell people is you have a
strong,
and I take my kids out that right.
And I've trained them at a very early
age to go out there,
the jump in the cold pool,
but they'll stand in front of the cold
pool and calm their nervous system,
call them their heart rate.
I'll have them visit like one of them
visualizes a sea otter,
right?
And the other one does a polar bear.
So,
so they'll visualize these animals that
are just like impervious to cold,
right?
And then they get in the water and they
know there's no sharp intake of breath.
There's no
like,
like people do when they take a cold
shower a lot of the time.
If you can get your body that point,
I think that it probably has a pretty,
it's a good indicator that you're
building that nervous system resilience,
right?
Like if you can just get in cold and not
freak out.
Right.
So that's what I think people who do
cold should train themselves to be able
to do.
I've heard that argument about the sauna
as well.
It also builds like a mental toughness
to be able to just sit in there and calm
yourself and get used to the adverse,
get to the point where you want to bang
down the door and climb out.
And yeah,
that's what I like to get myself to in
the song because obviously you get a
bigger expression of heat shock protein
and more blood flow when you get really
hot.
But yeah,
there's a mental effect too.
Same thing with the water is talking
about that book,
but the book deep and how I got into
like free diving and spear fishing.
God,
Dph,
I think you would love to do it.
I told you I'm going to go hunt down.
He was telling me that it's like hunting
underwater.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
actually,
yeah,
Aubrey and I,
Auburn and I spear fished in a,
and Kona,
uh,
last year,
he and Whitney and I went down there and
we were just using like the little three
pronged guns.
It wasn't full on like 80 feet deep.
You know,
big ass guns after Mina,
after tuna.
Jesus Christ.
People go out there like dee,
I've,
I've never done deal,
I'm not good enough.
Like I'm under water.
I attached to a tune a high,
well what you do is you have a real and
real is attached to a float,
right?
And so after you shoe and you spiro big
fish like a tuna,
it's not dragging you.
It's dragging the float.
So all you have to do is wait for that
float to pop back up wherever it's going
to pop up.
And that's how,
but I haven't done that.
But that's like on my bucket list.
Big Time.
I'm going back to Kona,
I'm going back to Kona in April and
that's going to be more shallow water,
spear fishing.
And we're going to hunt for a scrub
cattle.
Sheep go,
you know the pig there was amazing.
They have a scrub cat.
Yeah.
And the pig feet on like macadamia nuts
and avocado and explaining the old scrub
catalyst and scrub calendar this.
But apparently it tastes amazing.
What's Grub Bulls are,
they're essentially domestic cattle that
have gone feral.
So some time in the past,
whether it's 10,
20 generations back,
whatever it was,
they busted through some fences and now
they're wild.
And uh,
in Australia they hunt and they are very
dangerous.
Apparently they are the most aggressive
bowls bringing on,
I can't wait gotta be real careful.
Adam Green trees buddies got gored real
bad and you had to be medivaced out of
there.
He was in the the northern country.
I'm just going to play a Shitload of
techno hunt.
So,
so,
so the book,
I read this book by James Nest Door and
in,
I had him on my podcast and I'm like
dude,
I want to learn how to do this.
I want,
I want to learn how to like compress the
spleen and go under and learn how to
hold my breath and get all these nervous
system benefits,
spleen.
The spleen just gets compelling.
I'll learn how to get deep enough cause
I couldn't even as an Ironman
triathlete,
I couldn't go deeper than 15 feet
without freaking out.
Cause like my,
my ears,
we'd get the pressure in them and I
could do the,
what do you call it,
the,
um,
when you equalize,
not the Frenzel technique but the,
it's the,
uh,
you know,
when you,
when you go,
yeah,
I'm forgetting the name of pop your
ears,
pop your ears technique that most people
do when they get into the water.
But there's another technique called the
Frenzel technique where you'll,
you'll pull the,
it's like,
and you,
so you're doing it just to see like your
dose by dose goes out like that.
You do that,
you can equalize it like 20 feet,
30 feet,
40 feet.
So I said,
who can I go learn from?
He,
he's like,
you gotta go see this cat down in Fort
Lauderdale named Ted Hardcore.
It's Florida and got to go back to
Florida.
Everything absolutely explains Dick
shocks to the stem cells.
Got to learn how to do the splitting
thing.
So I go to,
fortunately,
my grandmother lives in Florida,
so I,
I have a place to stay when I go there.
So there's that at least.
Uh,
and I take this free diving course and
he gets me from holding my breath for
about a minute and 45 seconds.
He got me up to four 45,
four magnum breath for five seconds.
It took me from 15 fee over five days
down to 80 feet where you're like trout,
you,
you actually,
they put a rope in the water and you go
vertical and you have like your bit,
you know the big thins,
like you have the big fins and you have
Hamas that,
I've seen those on people,
but they're,
they're like path as long as that flag,
what's that like?
Like three,
four feet.
But that,
yeah,
they're like these big carbon fans.
And I said,
dude,
just tell me all of the best things to
buy.
And I contacted the editor of carbon,
so they're stiff and their car when
they're stiff and you just swim soul
fast in them.
And I contacted the editor of spearing
magazine and asking me what's the best
gun to buy,
what are the best fans?
But,
so I,
I got outfitted with all this stuff and
then I went down there,
learn how to hold my breath,
learn how to equalize.
And now when I spear fish and I still,
again,
I haven't got to the point where I've
gone,
like I go after the group or,
and the parrot fish and like the,
the little ones,
I haven't gotten to the point now where
I'm hunting.
The big fish is very similar to,
I know the very first time I went after
my,
I got two at once to groupers at once
and apparently it wasn't group per
season,
so they had me put him,
put him back.
It's not as big of a deal is like if you
shoot an elk and you know,
I'm a tag,
I mean like,
but,
but yet they have a group person.
I mean not put them back.
I didn't like take them down to their
little group or nest and them away.
But they're dead.
So you can,
yeah,
you just leap.
Yeah.
You just lead them.
That seems ridiculous.
Well,
I mean it just didn't want to get fine.
They didn't want to get in trouble.
All right,
so,
so anyways,
the spearfishing,
amazing.
And this whole like free diving,
you know,
we,
we got on this topic from the float
tanks,
similar experience.
Like you're just at peace under the
water.
You're not wearing all the scuba
equipment.
So fish swim up to you and you can kind
of like lay on the bottom of the water
and you know,
shoot something as it comes.
I go with my kids and they like sit on
the shore with like buckets and and
dives and you know,
they'll help,
help bring the fish and then we'd take
it back.
And you have like fish cook offs and
it's amazing.
He's very similar to but very similar
field of bow hunting except it's like
that peaceful setting in the water.
It's probably intensely physical while
it's a great workout cause you're not on
there,
you're cold.
So you're getting all the benefits of
cold thermogenesis,
you know,
like the white adipose to Brown fat
conversion and the,
and the shivering and the,
and the calorie burning.
And you know that angiogenesis and all
the stuff you get from cold.
But then you're also,
you're freaking hunting,
right?
We're not sitting on the edge like with
a,
with a fishing pole over a boat,
which I find intensely boring.
You're actually in there and you're
doing all while you're holding with the
fish,
doing it all while you're holding your
breath.
Now Scuba equipment and people will do
like,
like I do breath hold walks.
All right,
well go on a walk and every time I pass
a telephone pole,
I'll just like take a breath and I'll
hold my breath as long as possible in a
pasta.
Tell it when I passed the telephone pole
and they'll breathe through my nose to
recover.
And then when I get to the next
telephone pole,
I'll hold my breath.
Probably gonna die some day like next to
a bus stop.
Like a car blue in the face.
But yeah,
spear fit.
Like you'd like it.
I'm sure.
I would think you'd dig it.
Yeah.
It seems like an interesting mental
exercise table because you have to keep
your shit together while you're at the
water and you're wanting to take a
breath.
You do.
And people die.
People do shallow water blackout and
this is what I learned.
That's why I,
this guy sent me down to Fort Lauderdale
because this guy,
he teaches safety,
right?
You don't do like the Wim Hoff breathing
and blow off all the carbon dioxide so
you can hold your breath longer,
which is great for holding your breath
longer.
But carbon dioxide is your body's signal
to take a breath.
If you're real,
all of your carbon dioxide,
then here,
so you have to have walk out.
So for example,
you're floating on the water before
you're going to take a dive down.
She kind of like watching the water,
you're watching the fish and you might
do like a two count breath in to count
hold and then 10 count breath out to
count hold.
And you're just like getting the heart
rate down.
You're getting the nervous system calm.
You're not even supposed to do like a
lot of caffeine which jacks up the
[inaudible] system and cause you to not
be able to hold your breath as long
dairy makes the mucus more thick and so
you,
you can't hold your breath as long as
you do a of dairy.
So you don't do a lot of dairy,
you don't do a lot of caffeine and then
you just dive down.
And I did,
uh,
I brought ketones down because a lot of
like a dominique d'agostino has,
has,
you know,
he's done research on like a divers and
reducing a lot of the effects of like
reduced a reduced flow of oxygen to the
brain that apparently these,
these navy seal divers get and he does
research on,
on the use of Ketosis and ketones.
And one of the days that we were out
there,
I actually took a key tones and the
increased my breath hold time just using
like these,
these exogenous ketones.
So apparently they have an effect as
well.
I don't know if it's because the brain
is using more,
more of the ketones and the glucose,
but they increase breath hold time that,
yeah,
they,
they came up with that for rebreathers.
Right.
Like that's when they started getting
people maybe seal divers when they're
using rebreathers apparently in a
certain percentage of them are
susceptible to seizures.
Yeah.
And they use a,
well two things,
you know,
ketosis and,
and cbd are two things that are used for
the,
for like epilepsy and seizures.
Yeah.
Ketosis supposedly has an amazing effect
with kids,
kids and did a seizures.
I did 12 months of like strict Ketosis,
a four study for a lab study in Florida.
No,
I'm just kidding.
That's a university of Connecticut.
This guy named um,
uh,
Jeff Volak.
He does a lot of like ketone research
and he had one group of athletes follow
just a normal and Darren's athlete Diet
for 12 months and another group follow
like a high fat low carb Ketogenic Diet
for 12 months because he wanted to see
if you would maintain your glycogen
levels and if you would,
uh,
if your performance would be synonymous
to the group that did not eat the high
fat,
low carb Diet,
what would happen to inflammatory
markers?
What would happen to the gut microbiome?
So,
but he wanted like a lot of these
studies on high fat,
low carb diets.
They'll follow people for like two weeks
or three days and have meat like high
fat,
low carb and then see what happens when
they go jam on a bike for 30 minutes or
exercise.
But they want to do like a longterm
study to see if the body can adapt to
burning fats as a fuel with long term
utilization of a high fat diet,
which I don't do any more by the way.
I,
I like,
I save all my carbohydrates for the
evening.
Then I eat a bunch of carbohydrates in
the evening.
What kind of carbs you eat?
Oh,
like a red wine.
Dark chocolate too.
Or starches,
yams,
sweet potatoes.
You my,
my wife's a cook,
so she does like this amazing like slow
fermented sourdough bread,
which pre digest all the gluten and the
doors.
The glycaemic index,
like pretty much keen wa Amaranth,
millet.
I don't follow a specific diet in terms
of like restricting certain food groups.
My philosophy is you just make them
digestible,
eating carbs at night that it's good
thing to relax you as well.
Technically you're more insulin
sensitive in the morning,
but you can make yourself more insulin
sensitive in the evening and the
advantage of that is if you consume a
bunch of your carbohydrates in the
morning when you're in an insulin
sensitive state,
what are you going to rely upon as your
primary fuel during the rest of the day?
Karma hydrates,
right?
Instead of teaching your body how to be
a fat burning machine and tap into fats
and generate ketones.
So you save your carbohydrate intake for
the end of the day.
But I also saved my hard workout for the
end of the day,
which is when your body temperature
peaks and your grip strength peaks and
uh,
you,
you can do a hard workout.
And anybody who's rolls out of bed and
tried to do a crossfit wad versus doing
it,
you know,
the 5:00 PM the afternoon knows this.
Like you can do it pretty good hard
workout like in the later afternoon or
the evening when you're warmed up.
But that also upregulates insulin
sensitivity and the activity of these
glute four transporters that can shove
glucose in the muscle tissue for
example.
And so then you can have your cake and
eat it too,
right?
You,
you create your own insulin sensitive
state and then you go off and,
and typically I'll finish that workout
around like six,
six 30 right?
And like I mentioned,
I don't eat dinner for a couple hours
after the workout is like a eight 30 we
sit down to a family dinner and I'll
just use as many carbohydrates as I want
because I'm in an insulin sensitive
state by the next morning and I tested
this for a while.
I did like the blood ketone and the
breath ketone testing.
I'm back in a fat burning state by the
next morning,
but also with the bread,
I've also replenish my glycogen stores
and my liver and my muscle to be able to
do the next days.
Hard workout.
Right?
So I like this strategy for athletes
because they can get all the benefits of
a fat burning state.
The reduced free radical production from
excess glucose intake,
the reduced young glycaemic variability,
which is honestly a,
it's a,
it's a pretty big marker for in my
opinion,
like like your risk factor for a host of
chronic diseases like spiking your blood
glucose multiple times during the day.
So instead you just don't eat
carbohydrates all day,
do a hard workout at the end of the day
and then have your carbohydrates to
replenish all your energy levels.
Then you go into the next day.
And then what's your primary food source
during the day?
Like what do you do?
You have like standards so you,
we,
we have a lot of like really good wild
plants that grow up in the,
on our land.
So I have 10 acres up there in
Washington state and we've got like
wild,
not all and meant and plantation and
Oregon grape root and comfrey and all
these amazing plants.
So we also have eight raised garden beds
where we grow Kale and Bok Choy,
Swiss chard.
And so raise them so that they don't
learn.
They're not as obsessed stubble to
ground frost or like when you raise a
garden bed,
you can just add whatever type of soil
that you want versus digging down,
cause my wife does a lot of composting
because we have chickens and goats.
So she used a lot of the,
a lot of the dung from the chickens and
the goats.
And the leftover food from inside and
does composting.
And so we use a lot of this and the
raised garden beds.
Nice.
I started gardening this year.
Indoors,
I'm growing something called spilanthes,
which I can tell you about later.
It's amazing.
I found an inquiry.
But the um,
the what I do during the day and eat a
lot of wild plants,
right?
So,
so I'll come in when I'm coming in from
like that cold pool in the morning.
I like gathering some plants and I throw
those in a blender with like some,
some fats like coconut milk or coconut
oil,
uh,
all the,
like some bone broth and some lemon
because when you mix the vitamin C with
college and you make the college and a
lot more absorbable.
So I'll mix the vitamin C with bone
broth.
I'll put that into the blender.
A whole bunch of superfoods.
Don't blend it for like two minutes.
Cause if you blend it for a long time,
it gets like a texture,
like a Wendy's frosty.
So it's like,
and you can like eat it with,
with,
you know,
one of those long you've had a wendy's
frosty for,
right?
Yeah.
You look confused when I said Wendy's
fries.
Strange.
What kind of horrible life you led.
What did your parents do to you?
You never had a wendy's frosty,
so,
so it gets like this Wendy's frosty like
consistency.
It's just a bunch of wild plants and
fats.
And I put like that Stevia in there.
I put a little bit of mccowen there.
Uh,
sometimes we'll do like a little bit of
whey protein,
like a good like grass fed whey or some
kind of protein source.
And then I put like a crunchy things and
so I put it all in a bowl with a spatula
crunchy.
Yeah.
Like coconut flakes and could count
hibbs and uh,
like I use like these little spiralina
and chlorella tablets.
And so it's like eating a,
it's like when you go to a yogurt store
and you get the yogurt and you get the
toppings on top of it,
but it's like this amazing Kenogenic
superfood rich meal.
And by blending it all together and
blending the fats with all the,
all the ingredients,
you're actually enhancing the
absorption.
And so,
so that's what I have for breakfast.
You should open a cafe.
So that sounds good.
Well I'm trying to like,
I'm trying to make it into like a,
uh,
like a drinkable,
a drinkable form.
Something that is the same thing that
um,
yeah,
I'm going over to see,
uh,
Rick Ruben after this over in Malibu and
he does the same thing for breakfast.
And that's actually one of the things
we're talking about how we can make this
no so random.
Like we,
we go sauna together over there in
Malibu and we were,
uh,
we both do the same thing.
Like his,
his,
his is a little bit different.
Like he put some different things in it
at the same thing and it's an amazing
breakfast cause you can sit there and
like I do a lot of dictation on my
computer,
so I'll sit there and I'll dictate
emails.
But while I'm eating my,
my smoothie with a spoon,
it's amazing.
And then I do a salad for breakfast or
for lunch,
a big ass salad.
Again,
whole bunch of wild plants and I'll put
like sardines,
seeds,
nuts,
you know,
just,
just good,
good fats on them.
And,
uh,
then I have like these Nori wraps,
right,
which is like a seaweed wrap.
You're really good in iodine.
Really nutrient dense.
And I'm gonna use miracle noodles.
Have you had miracle noodles?
No.
So they're made out of Japanese Yam,
they called them.
Sure.
Talky noodles.
It's in my kids make pad Thai out of
this and they have like a cooking
podcast where they do all these crazy
crazy meals.
And one of the things they use a lot of
are these shirataki noodles.
So I make these Japanese Yam and it was,
I put him on top of the salad and then I
roll that up and like a noi,
Burrito wrap.
And I eat that like a Burrito for lunch.
And then dinner,
like I mentioned,
it's just,
you know,
whatever my wife happens because dinner
is Mike,
my free mail.
Right.
It's just whatever I want to have.
But for this study for Jeff Volek Slab
is 12 months strict ketosis and they
brought us into the lab.
Uh,
they had me in the,
in the group of Kenogenic athletes and
also the whole group of,
of endurance athletes following a
traditional carbohydrate rich diet,
uh,
do a vo two Max test the night that we
got there.
And then the next morning they punched a
bunch of holes and our thighs with
needles and did a biopsy of the muscle
to see how much glycogen was in the
muscle.
And then with these big holes in our,
in our muscles,
we had to go run on a treadmill for
three hours.
So I ran 22 miles on the,
on the whole like look up,
like wanting to see how much do they
want to see,
how much glycogen they pull.
It's like a muscle biopsy.
It's like a little bleak Ghia team.
That's a big deal,
especially when you go pound on the
treadmill after you've had these,
these needle biopsies and your thighs.
And then they did fat biopsy because
they wanted to look at fat content up on
either side of the hips.
And then I ran for three hours on this
treadmill and it was horrible.
There was like no TV.
There's no,
no,
there's a white wall on the treadmill.
But they,
and,
and I was hooked up to like a a,
you know,
like,
like a,
a blood collection device because it
was,
what am I in the night I had a Walkman
and a,
I had my,
I had my mouth,
my aerobics socks on like Jane Fonda
back in the day.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And my running,
so you just running single hour staring
at the walls around for three hours.
Stats gotta be the worst part of it is
horrible.
Yeah.
I didn't know going in,
I walked in the room and I'm like,
Oh shit.
Cause I would have brought,
you know like yeah,
just something to watch.
But I ran and they were testing fat
oxidation rates at rest and an exercise.
So I'm wearing this,
this mask,
it's,
it does what's called indirect
calorimetry where based on the carbon
dioxide that you breathe out,
the oxygen that you consume,
it approximates your carbohydrate and
your fat burning.
Right.
It's Kinda like the gold standard of,
of metabolic testing in laboratory
testing situations like in an exercise
physiology lab.
And so you're,
you're testing how much fat you're
burning during exercise,
how much carbohydrate you're burning
during exercise,
something called your,
your respiratory exchange ratio.
Is that what it's called?
And the prevailing uh,
research and the literature suggests
that you can burn about 1.0 grams of fat
per minute during exercise.
Like that would be about how much fat
you would burn 1.0 grams of fat per
minute.
When they tested,
this was called the faster study f.
They found that the folks who fall at a
high fat diet like me and these other
people who were eating high fat diet,
we were burning 1.5 to 1.7 grams of fat
per minute during exercise.
During this three hour treadmill run.
We had no deficit in performance.
Our Vo Two max is we're just as high and
we maintained our levels of muscle
glycogen.
And so basically there was no,
we didn't go any faster,
but I'm not saying like,
like a Kenogenic diet is going to keep
better at endurance sports cause I've
never seen any evidence that that's
going to happen.
But we did go just as fast and we
actually burnt,
we turned our bodies into fat burning
machines over the course of 12 months.
It was actually a really cool study.
So the benefits would not be necessarily
performance,
but the benefits are more health tips.
It's like,
you know,
a lot of people like they get gut rot
and fermentation from eating a lot of
fermentable carbohydrates.
Some people get small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth.
Um,
some people get blood glucose
fluctuations.
Uh,
you see,
uh,
you see a drop in what's called the
first phase insulin response.
Like normally you're supposed to produce
a lot of insulin when you eat a meal or
at least enough to be able to shove that
sub straight into storage tissue.
And normally you'd be able to produce
this.
And by getting a lot of glycaemic
variability during the day,
you eventually produce insulin
insensitivity,
right?
Like you don't have that normal first
phase insulin response and you can,
you can restore it.
You know,
you can use things like bitters and chew
your food a lot and you know,
strength trained before you eat a
carbohydrate rich meal and you know,
things like that.
But ultimately,
uh,
yeah,
it's more of like a health and longevity
thing.
It's not like a like eating low
carbohydrate makes you faster.
It's just that you avoid a lot of the
potential issues,
the potential health issues that would
come with a large amount of glucose
fluctuations.
But there's exceptions to that rule.
Or like you could go get your genetics
tested and you might find out,
you have,
let's say familial hypercholesterolemia,
right?
In which case if you eat like a key
topic diet,
you'll produce a lot of like oxidized
and you'll see people with cholesterol
like 400,
500 and really high lp,
little a and all these issues with a
high amount of fat consumption because
their bodies are unable to deal with
that amount of cholesterol.
Um,
that's a big point.
That's a big point.
The customers can't stress that enough.
Is it human beings?
Very so.
And the huge,
yeah,
huge amount.
Like a,
there's a great book that Brian Count
turned me onto that I'm reading right
now called Sapiens,
the origins of human beings.
It's completely fascinating.
It's crazy.
There's another book called biochemical
individuality.
It's like an old book,
but I was looking through,
it's fascinating like,
like there's like 12 different shapes of
the stomach and like seven different
ways that the hardest shaped and certain
people will excrete copious amounts of
vitamin D and need a lot more vitamin D
intake and other people develop vitamin
D toxicity in response like the 2000 and
4,000 international units that a lot of
people are popping in these days.
Certain people develop high cholesterol
and high triglycerides and high
inflammation in response to to a
ketogenic diet and some people don't.
And so like we live in an era where it's
like it's cheap to get your genes tested
and it's only going to get cheaper.
Well,
it's also theirs.
You'd have to really find a good expert
that really understands what the
difference in the genetic variability
is.
Our,
yeah,
I mean like otherwise you're just
testing,
like you're trying to ketogenetic diet,
testing out your blood work and trying
to figure it out.
It's very complicated to the,
for the lay person it is.
But I mean like in very simplistic
terms,
I've told some people that that's right.
You could at least test your genetics
and there's actually a really good book
about this called uh,
um,
the jungle effect by Doctor Daphne
Miller.
And she goes into how like she'll put
like her,
her Hispanic clients on like a
traditional Mexican diet comprised of
like,
you know,
uh,
soaked and sprouted legumes and low
glycemic index,
you know,
tortillas and non gmo corn and take them
back to what their ancestors would have
eaten.
Like she'll literally take like what the
Tar Mahara Indian drive is eating and
South America and put her Hispanic
clients on that.
Or she'll put like her African American
clients on a fiber rich fermented like
Cambodian diet and,
and you could easily do it like it's not
rocket science,
right?
You go,
your genetics tested,
you see where your ancestors came from
and you try to approximate,
and obviously we're a genetic melting
pot in America and there's gonna be some
people who are just like,
oh crap I came from,
I come from Japan and Europe and
Ethiopia.
You know,
like there's some people who come from
all over the place,
in which case you would have to take a
deeper dive,
right?
You can get blood work,
you can get,
what I tell people is get your genes
tested like a comprehensive blood
analysis.
Get your gut tested,
right?
So you could look at your bacterial
balance,
presence of parasites,
yeast,
fungus,
all those kinds of little things that
that affect gut health and personality
and everything else at the microbiome
affects.
Uh,
and then like a,
like a urine test for hormones,
which is more accurate than a blood
test.
That's a lot of testing.
But if you really,
really truly want to dial things in its
genetic testing,
it's blood testing,
urinary testing for hormones.
There's a test called a,
the,
the Dutch test.
It tests like your testosterone all
throughout the day.
The metabolites of testosterone and your
cortisol all throughout the day,
the metabolites of Cortisol.
So you could actually see like,
you know,
do I really have high cortisol or am I
just not breaking it down quickly
enough?
For example,
I just wish there was a place that you
could go that was very comprehensive
that the average person go to where they
could do all this stuff for you and
break it down for you.
That seems like there's more and more of
a market of that test.
Every thousand dollars.
It's the Hue.
Actually.
There is a place like it's like the
human,
there's,
you know,
some of these guys who were like trying
to live forever.
Like,
uh,
I think one of them is,
is Peter Diamandis.
Uh,
Craig venter I think is another guy.
He's like the human human longevity
institute,
I think it's called.
Yeah,
like some of these,
some of these rich dudes,
right?
Like a lot of these billionaires,
they're going to this place as and in
getting like the comprehensive blood
testing done.
I,
I do a lot of that myself just by
ordering it,
you know,
from like direct labs are these little,
you have a deep understanding and
knowledge about all this stuff.
It's different than the average price on
injecting stem cells into the mind.
But I think for the average person
that's listening to this,
it's uh,
it's a little confusing and maybe a
little frustrating because it would be
nice if there was a place that you'd go
with the,
like the dentist,
you go to the dentist,
Hey bob,
you've got a cavity.
It's all pretty straight.
Exactly that will,
there's companies working on that right
now.
Like,
like an actual dashboard where you get a
home test kit done and they're like,
they're actually like microneedles now
that you can attach to the scan that you
patch it on yourself,
you send off a tiny,
tiny amount of blood and you'd get a
host of blood values back and then you
would be able to see like what you have
deficits in.
And I could totally see them pairing
that with like food delivery companies
are like,
you know,
even just like printouts.
So like,
here's your protein,
carb fat ratio.
Right?
It'll happen.
Now,
when you were on the strict Ketogenic
Diet for 12 months,
what was your diet like?
What did you basically eat?
No Italian.
Great.
When you got off,
I remember what I was like my
bodybuilding days where like you go way
in like in the morning before the show
and then the rest of the day you eat
like freaking ice cream and bread and
you look like just like an Olympic God
when you get up on stage cause
everything's popping right.
Like all that glycogen gets restored
after about eight hours.
Uh,
the,
how does that work on my first meal?
Well,
when you don't eat many carbohydrates,
you upregulate levels was something
called glycogen synthase,
which is an enzyme responsible for
helping to get glycogen in the muscle
tissue.
This would be a process that you would
do before,
like Aj and depletion followed by
glycogen restoration causes this big
surge in glycogen plus going into a
show,
you're restricting carbohydrates anyways
because it's hard to get very,
very low body fat.
That's why you see bodybuilders eating
fricking like chicken and Broccoli,
right?
So,
um,
the,
the same thing.
It's something I did when I did
triathlon.
Right.
You'll like carbohydrate deplete the
weekend before a race.
And then I used to do this.
You'd eat no carbohydrates on Saturday
and Sunday for a race that follows the
next Sunday.
And then Monday you'd start to eat more
carbohydrates Tuesday even more.
And by like Saturday before the Ray
Street and like 90% carbohydrate.
This is what I did before I kind of
trained my body to like,
you know,
ketosis and function while on a low carb
diet.
But it,
you're just,
I mean you're jacked up chock full of
glycogen cause you upregulate that
enzyme.
It's called a,
what's it called?
Carbohydrate.
Let's just basically carbohydrate
depletion,
carbohydrate loading.
So was there any benefit of that
performance wise versus what you're
doing now?
Um,
there's,
there's not necessarily a benefit in
that you,
uh,
you go faster if you've trained your
body how to operate well on a low
carbohydrate diet.
I've never,
like I said,
seen any evidence that like a low
carbohydrate ketogenetic diet makes you
go faster than if you were eating like a
regular like carbohydrate rich diet.
But I also haven't seen that.
If you do like I did and follow it
strict for a long time.
There's not a lot of evidence that makes
you go slower either.
So it's kind of like,
it's like even as a kid,
right?
So it's just a health longevity Ben.
It's more of like,
hey,
if I can live a longer time and feel
better and produce less reactive oxygen
species by doing this versus the high
carbohydrate intake,
then why not do it?
And I mean when you look at like the
Nike project and how they were to break
the marathon record in Italy,
they were using like these crazy
engineered forms of carbohydrate where
they went way above like these
Maltodextrin,
fructose blends that a lot of companies
like,
you know,
like gatorade use and they were using
these super engineered carbs.
It's possible that some of these newer
carbohydrates that are engineered for
extremely high absorption could,
could beat out.
Like if we were to study those in like
a,
you know,
a high fat,
low carb athlete who had followed that
diet for a long period of time versus
like a traditionally fueled athlete who
was eating these new fangled engineered
carbohydrates.
It's possible the new fangled engineered
carbohydrates could make you go faster
button unless your paycheck is on the
line and you're a pro.
I still say,
why not get that balance between health
and longevity and speed.
My thyroid though did not like that high
fat ketogenic diet director paired with
high levels of physical activity.
My testosterone went down were like
there were some issues.
That's fascinating because usually you
hear the opposite.
People with thyroid disease,
they recommend a ketogenic diet to those
people.
Yeah.
But look at it this way and I explained
this to to a lot of athletes who I work
with who wanted to do the ketogenic diet
thing.
You read,
uh,
you know,
you read a book like a,
there's some fantastic ketogenic diets
out there that are plant rich,
which a lot of ketogenetic diets aren't
right?
Like there'll be like coconut oil and
butter and that actually creates a lot
of gastric inflammation.
In the absence of,
of like,
you know,
high amount of polyphenols and
flavonoids and high fiber and planning
type like you want both.
I wrote an article about this called the
dark side of coconut oil that gets into
the fact that if you're going to do like
a high fat,
low carb Ketogenic type of diet,
you would want to include a lot of
plants and like uh,
a Dr. Terry Walls is a book called the
walls protocol that's got a plant rich
kenogenic version it.
Um,
Steven gundry has his book,
the plant paradox and he has like a,
he has like a ketogenic version in that
book that's like very plant rich.
So if,
if you're eating like a,
like a plant rich keto genic diet and
you're following what a lot of these
people I've written,
you generally be advised he like 30 to
50 grams of carbohydrates per day,
which is fine if you have thyroid
disease or you have some other issue,
you know,
pre diabetes,
whatever,
and you're trying to control it with a
ketogenic diet.
But then once you throw copious amounts
of physical activity into the mix,
right?
Your crossfit or you're an Ironman
triathlete and you go read the one of
these books and you read the supposed to
be 50 grams of carbohydrates,
well you know,
the authors of those books,
to my knowledge are not out racing
ironman triathlons and doing marathons
and copious amounts of physical
activity.
So you have to up the carbohydrate
intake.
So it's all about,
you know,
so for me personally,
like a hundred to 200 grams of
carbohydrate,
it's still bad tanky carbohydrate feed.
At the end of the day I'll still
maintain ketosis.
And so you again,
you have your cake and eat it too.
That's a radical physical output though.
You're taking.
Exactly.
So if you have like a thyroid issue and
you're highly active and you want to
follow Ketogenic Diet,
then you need to include more
carbohydrates than it would be
recommended in let's say like a more
sedentary type of ketone giant die
because you're always reading these
diets based on just the average person
and the average person is just not going
to put out that kind of APP.
You want to include a lot of the things
that that you tend to build up deficits
in like potassium and magnesium or two
biggies and you dump a lot of glycogen
and glycogen stores,
a bunch of water and it stores a bunch
of electrolytes.
You have to figure out how to replace
that and now people are using,
you know these,
these exogenous ketones,
the ketone salts or Ketone esters and
the danger with those is now you can
like get into ketosis but still also
have high blood glucose and that's
something that we haven't really
studied.
Like that's not like our ancestors out
hunting right for that.
Like it's not like were in ketosis
because they were burning a lot of their
own body fat.
And generating keytones as a byproduct.
And they were,
they were in just like a natural state
cause they weren't eating a lot of food.
Sometimes just,
you know,
not stuffing their face with
carbohydrates and glucose.
But now people are able to eat a normal
western diet and like buy one of these
ketone supplements and also be in
Ketosis.
So you're hyperglycemic and
hyperkeratotic.
And I've like,
I did that before race and I felt like I
was on steroids.
Like it was like rocket fuel because my
blood glucose was jacked through the
roof.
But so I did a bunch of like fructose
Maltodextrin,
energy based gels,
and then I drank a bottle of these
ketone esters,
which basically,
I mean the,
they have,
if you measure your ketones,
you'll,
you'll know that this is high.
But within 10 minutes,
my values were above seven millimolar,
which is just off the charts for
ketones.
But my blood glucose was also off the
charts.
And I felt like my cells had like both
forms of fuel they'd ever need,
both ketones and glucose.
And I felt amazing.
But all bet,
I mean that's similar like diabetic
ketoacidosis.
Like,
if you're in that state all the time and
you're using all these ketone
supplements and just eating your diet
and using these cause your quote in
Ketosis Unquote,
I don't think it's healthy.
I wonder if it would be great though
performance wise,
like for a fight.
It's amazing.
You feel unstoppable.
I would think that,
I wonder if athletes I've tried and as
long as you use that is,
it's like a,
it's like you use it as a,
you know,
it's like heard somebody say when it's
like sugars are sometimes drug,
right?
Cause it does like you can feel it and
can give you,
especially if you're,
if you're not fat adapted,
I mean carbohydrates give you a pretty
big boost in performance and energy
versus not having them on board and
you're exercising and especial or
exercising hard and this would be like
that,
right?
Like if you were to use that as a
sometimes drug and be careful with it.
Um,
I could see that being a huge,
like it was kind of a bump where you
going to like,
um,
I didn't quantify it.
If you try to use it was,
it was,
it was a tough mudder in Vegas and all I
know is I felt way,
way more.like,
like I had the cognitive high that you
get from ketones,
which was the original reason that I
started doing,
like I started doing this ketosis thing
like seven years ago when I was getting
ready to race iron man Canada.
And I wanted to see what it would feel
like to have those readily available
fuel sources for the liver and the
diaphragm and the heart and kind of the
focus that comes with high levels of
ketones when you're on a bike for five
hours.
And I had that when I took these
exogenous ketones,
but then I also had all the energy that
you get when you just,
you know,
like after you've had like a,
like a candy bar,
right?
So it's,
yeah,
your high blood sugar and high blood
ketones.
So you'd,
so you'd just feel focused,
but you also have high levels of energy.
That sounds amazing.
That's amazing.
I just like the stem cells in the tech
cry.
It's amazing.
I hope it's good.
I hope I don't die.
Yeah.
That sounds like though if you were
doing a big event and if you didn't do
it up to the like,
I like what you're doing is in terms of
diet wise it seems like it makes sense.
I've got a really good balance,
but for a big event that sounds like
it'd be a really good thing to do.
Look it up on carbohydrates,
load up on the ketone esters.
Right,
exactly.
Tonessa ketone esters are expensive.
Yeah,
and a lot of these ketone salts you
don't like about the ketone salts too
is,
I haven't seen a lot of resources at the
ketone esters are necessarily that much
better.
And the ketone salts,
you get electrolytes with them too.
Right,
and that's one of the things that you
get depleted on.
I'm like,
what ketogenetic do you know what,
what brand you're using for your ketone
supplements?
Dude,
I told you I'm like,
as a blogger I get these packages sent
to my house every day.
Just like you probably get the same
thing.
It's like cardboard boxes full of boxes
and occasional little paper bag.
It was something that somebody made in
their kitchen that they sent,
somebody gave me.
Uh,
so when we gave me,
when I was,
this was,
where was,
I think it was an Asheville doing a race
and Asheville,
North Carolina at Asheville fricking
great fat is oh,
crazy little spot.
I,
one of my clients took me to this place
called karate.
It's like a shark coolray like a fine
shark,
a restaurant.
Amazing me.
Amazing.
Apparently like a president,
President Obama's like favorite
restaurant wasn't Asheville and he'd go
there and you go up and down the street
and just,
I went there during the yoga festival
and there's like people sitting up in
trees playing banjos and like,
it's crazy.
It's amazing.
I definitely want to go back there.
Yeah,
the International Yoga Festival in
Asheville,
but the um,
shout out to Ashville,
Ashville,
baby Hashtag Asheville somebody gave me
like wine that they infused with
cannabis,
like at like this big bottle,
like cannabis infused wine.
But it was like one of those old school
like Kombucha bottles,
like the glass and you're just like,
I don't know where this has been.
[inaudible] I don't know what's in here.
Nope.
Um,
it was a cool idea,
but,
uh,
no offense to whoever gave me that,
but I didn't actually consume that.
But the,
uh,
the ketone salts and the ketone esters,
um,
honestly,
dude,
I've tried like all of them,
uh,
you know,
key genics and uh,
Kito I forget what the enteral Kido
something Keith keep genics and went to
school in Nashville and uh,
he said that they started giving the
cows a certain diet to kill the silicide
mushrooms that grow in their shit
because too many kids were climbing
fences and early and plucking mushrooms
out of the cow.
Shit.
You ever do that?
You ever do like the silicide been
microdosing thing that people are doing
for cognition?
I have silicide microdosed I've taken
and it gives you a nice feeling.
I like it gives you,
I have a friend who's a world champion
kickboxer who micro doses every day and
he says it him almost telepathic,
you says it makes his,
his response time to sparring.
He said he sees things before they
happen or sensory perception,
especially in nature settings,
right?
Like,
there's this,
there's like this synthetic chemical,
ella chemical,
LSD or pls.
LSD is like the one a lot of people are
using now cause you get it for a lot
less expensive and it,
it has the same effect as,
as LSD.
It's just,
it's,
it's a lot cheaper and you get both and
you don't like these websites where you
use cryptocurrency to,
to purchase the compound.
But the FBI sent it to you.
Exactly.
They dunt dunt dunt Duh.
You,
uh,
it's very synthetic and there's like a
merging of the left and right
hemispheres of the brain and you get
very creative and focus simultaneously
doses you,
uh,
for Lsd,
you,
you want to volume metrically dose,
which means like if you get a blotter of
Lsd,
it's like a hundred micrograms.
I'm like a square.
And a lot of people will cut that into
like 10 pieces.
So that one piece would be 10
micrograms.
But you don't know if that piece has
like 20 or five on it.
Right?
So you take a hundred a hundred
microgram tab and you put that in like a
little like a,
like a glass dropper bottle and then you
would add like 10 milliliters of
everclear or vodka or some kind of
alcohol to it.
And then you know that for every one
milliliter of alcohol in that little
dropper bottle that you consume,
you're getting exactly 10 micrograms of
LSD and about 10 to 20 micrograms,
like one to two dropper bottles full.
That would be considered a microdose for
most people.
But you don't like returning to
psilocybin.
Silicide produces like this sensory
perception,
very natural feeling,
uh,
improvement in your,
in your cognition and your senses that,
that it just feels more natural rights.
Like you,
you would take it before you go on on a
hike or you would take it when you're in
like a very,
very natural,
like a nature setting.
Like for something like a day at the
office.
Like it seems like Lsd is like a more
natural choice.
But suicide is really interesting for
like,
you know,
nature based setting,
hiking.
Well,
the thing about it is you feel like you,
you're getting readings from trees and
plants.
Yeah.
Get a weird feeling from the,
you don't normally get like,
oh now I'm tuned into whatever frequency
you guys are operating and they,
they feel alive.
Whereas trees just feel like trees.
Normally I walk by like they look
beautiful and,
but I don't feel them write the same
sentence.
Right,
exactly.
And,
and I mean,
you don't want to,
you don't want to make yourself
dependent on finding a tree beautiful by
whether or not you have silicide even a
beautiful turn blood stream.
Like it's communicating with you.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like exactly like they're giving
you information,
you save it for those settings when you
want nature to be really special.
Because my wife gives me a hard time
sometimes she was like,
you know,
why do you gotta take psilocybin for,
I got to go on a hike.
Like,
why don't you just go on a hike?
And I told her,
you know,
sometimes it's more interesting.
Sometimes you see things you wouldn't
normally otherwise see.
So,
you know,
I go to bed and I've got like my
binaural beats and my sleep mask and you
know,
I've got like that little grounding
earthing device under my body and my
chilly pad and uh,
you know,
blue light blocking glasses and,
and you know,
I get in bed with all these wires
sticking up out of my head and my wife
just gets in bed and just like sleeps
cause just got nothing on her side.
So we're very yin and Yang.
But you're still involved like
everything you're doing,
you're very involved.
Does it ever feel overwhelming that you
have all this stuff?
I mean obviously it's what you do cause
you,
you systematize it,
right?
Like when I walk into my office,
it's not like I'm spending 20 minutes
like turning on the turning on the Jews
of light and putting on the essential
oil diffuser and um,
uh,
you know,
I've got like a,
this,
this device that creates like special
water that you breathe.
Well,
you know,
humidifies the water that you breathe
while you're working.
And I've got like,
you know,
blue light generating devices on the
ceiling and all this stuff in my office.
But when I walk in there,
it's just like click,
click,
and I go to work right it with the thing
on my head or whatever.
So it's,
once you systematize it,
it's not exhausting.
It's not like you're doing a lot to
actually improve your body or you don't
say Bilac your body while you're,
while you're at work during a lot of
stuff just become systematized,
right?
It's like putting on your pants in the
morning.
The words about done,
I'm about done with that word.
Biohack were beaten up that word.
Now what I would consider to be
biohacking is,
you know,
these dudes that like in jet chlorella
into their eyes so that they could get
night vision.
You should pull that up.
Or,
or like,
uh,
Kevin,
Kevin Warrick,
like he was like the original Cyborg guy
who got like a chip implanted under the
skin or the people who will inject like
magnets in their fingertips to be able
to interact with devices.
So they would use the human body is what
they call wet ware and then install
hardware.
Like to me that's a true biohacker for
me to blend like curcumin with olive oil
and bone broth and vitamin C and my
smoothie.
That's not like a biohack.
That's just a health,
just like making a meal,
right?
Like it's,
it's like,
yeah.
Yeah.
So I took it too.
There are trending through bio hackers
out there who actually hacked their
biology but injecting chlorella in your
eyes.
Yeah,
it seems super risky actually.
You know,
I think its chlorophyll,
which is the,
which is the green active component that
you would find something like Chlorella,
but his eyes were all black.
It's really where you should pull it up,
Jamie.
Like dude injected ever.
I'm assuming.
I mean I don't think he could suck the
chlorophyll back out,
but he has night vision now or the guy
who is goat man.
Did you hear about Goldman?
No.
Hold on.
Let's one,
one step at a time.
You're almost manic and it's like,
I've got another one.
I got another one.
Hold on.
So this guy has permanent black in his
eyes and he can see like sorta like a
deer,
like nocturnal.
Oh yeah,
that's him.
That's okay.
Making science more available to the
public have been testing of chemicals
that allows humans to see in the dark
and it works.
That's a true bio.
Ha.
That's a correct use of the term
biohacking.
It's got some other people.
Then you can get like,
uh,
what's this on?
Nerdist.
Yeah.
nerdist.com there it goes straight into
the eye.
I'm not going to do that.
I will stop at the stem cells into my
Dick.
I'm not going to know things.
The speculum holding my eyes open was by
far the worst part.
Even the effects themselves were very
subtle.
It wasn't like,
oh my God,
I have Predator vision.
Nothing like that.
You don't get super powers.
This is a tweak,
not an overhaul.
It's kind of disappointing that you go
through all that for just the tweak.
Yeah.
Well your whole fucking eyes into that
shit.
I want Predator vision.
I want the full meal deal.
I want to be able to hunt animals in the
darkness.
Works by binding to ops and proteins in
your retina where it's excited by light
transformational process to occur in the
protein segment.
See,
there you go,
Huh?
Yeah.
So you could get the blue light blocking
glasses or you could just inject
everything into your eyes.
Allowed him pick to pick up figures in
the dark with 100% accuracy.
We're non treated test subjects.
You'd only make out to about 30% pretty
significant.
Well that would be really good.
And I liked it.
I liked how the author doesn't know
which percentage signed to use the
actual percentage sign or the word
percent.
Right.
They got to work on their,
on their editing.
That's interesting.
Your writer,
50 meters.
To go back to that Jamie,
we're talking 50 meters over 160 feet
apart.
Oh Wow.
That's actually really significant.
The following morning his eyes returned
to normal.
Oh,
I right.
Just say that right there is returned to
normal and side effects.
Oh Wow.
So he's not like that.
They're not injecting.
They're dropping.
They using drops.
So this would be like we were talking
about bow hunting about elk hunting.
Like,
like when you're in sort of low light,
that might be the mood,
could pack your speculum into your case,
drop them in there,
make sure that you have a hunting buddy
who is well versed in the addition of
chlorophyll,
rubber gloves,
rubber gloves.
You've got all that stuff to feel dress
anyways and just go to town on your
eyes.
How did you get into bow hunting?
Uh,
my buddy,
uh,
canton,
Claremont up in Washington state,
he was running these trained to
competitions which are really bad.
I also of course racing with a weapon,
it's a ton of,
and you could do it out here and like,
cause you have a,
like you could carry sandbags,
do like cones and suicides,
prints and all sorts of stuff with this
technical hunt set up that you have.
But that trying to hunt like uh,
the,
the first competition that I did you,
you show up and it starts off with like
a four or five hour traditional three d
shoot.
And for people who don't know what a
three d shoot is,
it's a bunch of targets,
you know,
like Reinhardt targets or whatever that
are set up.
Well explain that they different
locations to a jetty.
Look Robert Hill,
they look like animals are going to be a
fox or an or an elk or you know,
whatever.
You know,
uh,
a bedded animal or a standing animal and
they're spread throughout this course
that you're walking.
You can think of it almost like golfing,
you know,
for people who,
who don't bow hunt and you'll,
you know,
one shot might just be like a simple 25
yard shot at a Fox where if you get
vitals,
you'll get the five points.
And if you hit a body shot then it might
be three points.
And if you miss it's zero.
And if you get like a wound,
it's actually a negative score.
Right.
Which it should be like,
it's like a night.
Cause if you wound an animal that's,
that's really much,
much worse than missing an animal.
Right.
So some of the shots are pretty complex.
It might be you got to get off two shots
in 10 seconds,
which is actually kind of hard to do.
You know,
two shots in 10 seconds and one animals
at 20 and one animals at 40.
All right.
Which is why I use like a three pin side
on my ball because you don't even have
time to adjust the dial after you've
taken one shot to the yardage for the
second shot.
Um,
you might have a shot that's like run up
this hill.
There is a target up there.
We won't tell you the distance,
but you have 30 seconds to make it the
25 yards up that up,
that goalie.
And then you're going to have a shot at
the top and you got to run up the goal
he site and get your shot off in those
30 seconds.
Right?
So,
so it's not like a traditional three d
shoot.
It's very active,
you know,
and some shots are,
are you draw lunging and then you stand
and then you got to walk around the tree
and then take your shots.
So it's actually pretty fun.
It's way different than just like
standing out of the range,
shooting a target and you get a certain
score coming out of that,
right?
Like you might have a mass x number of
points or or lost x number of points and
then you go into,
um,
and they actually,
they,
this year they've kind of like changed
it because a lot of people were like
getting hurt and blowing out their knees
with this next part.
But you do what's called like a meat
pack,
which is a hundred pounds in your pack
and it's two to four mile course that
you got to boogie across as fast as
possible.
People were running.
And the problem with it was people like
when you pack out,
like you're taking it on time,
you're not running,
you're not like racing your buddy but
this,
and it was like the most painful thing
of really ever done in terms of like how
high my heart rate got and the amount of
lactic acid.
Like just try to go two miles fast.
You can with a hundred pounds in your
pack.
Sounds very not only you've got to spend
like I would spend copious amounts of
times like making sure the pack was
adjusted properly and I'll put like the
bubble wrap in the bottom of the pack.
So it moves the weight that you're
using,
which are typically sandbags up to the
center of the pack.
And I worked with this company called
[inaudible] that makes like these facts.
Yeah they make a jump back Aaron.
Um exactly.
And you know he did some skype sessions
with me where he taught me exactly cause
you don't set it up the way that you
would if you were just going to pack out
in animal,
you have to put it super duper tight up
in the shoulder so it's not bouncing
around.
And then you put the weight down in the
hips.
So it works for running two miles really
hard.
But it's super uncomfortable and it's
not biomechanically favorable sucks but
it's good to have it running.
Yeah.
So they call that the meat pack right.
And have to do it that way or is it just
a matter of how much weight you have on
your back?
Like if you could use one of those atlas
packs,
have you seen those atlas things from
outdoors means it's essentially it's a
pack frame with a traditional Olympic
boats on the end of it where you put the
plates on it.
What are those things called and then
the end of a weight bar or the white
wait slide on them.
What would you call that?
The end of a weight borrower.
The weights.
Like a barbell?
Yeah,
the end of the bar bar around the end of
the bar.
Well they have one of those I post,
I guess you've got to post.
Yeah.
They have one of those.
It's hanging out in the back.
See if you can find it.
It's called the atlas trainer Jamie
outdoorsman.
[inaudible] dot com um,
as a PAC.
It's PAC frame with a,
I hiked with it on this.
Is it a picture?
It's pretty dope.
Whoa.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Cool.
You could use whatever you want as long
as,
as long as you have waiting it.
You just have to figure out how to,
cause everybody has to use a standard
weight so you have to use the sandbag
that they issue to you.
Your use the same object that so
everybody's using a sand bag just so you
don't come in with your own weight.
I was just saying if he did that that
you like that you painted a 45 pound
logo on um,
anyways though she didn't meet,
pack in and he gives her amount of time
for that.
And then you do the obstacle course
which is the real hoot and which they
still do,
which is cause I think got rid of the
meat pack.
But the obstacle courses me pack it.
Well it's not,
it doesn't make sense,
right?
Like they designed this whole
competition to simulate hunting,
to prepare a hunter to hunt and to train
a hundred a hundred properly and it just
flew in the face of everything that is
hunting,
which is jacked up nervous system,
you know,
rushing through the woods with a giant
package.
You just,
you don't pack out an animal like that.
Then they'd have to figure out a way to
put like a speed limiter on like,
Oh hey,
you're not allowed to run.
So you guys got there.
What makes sense?
But people were getting hurt and it just
didn't,
didn't make sense.
I'd be jacked up my back and like it,
it's cool.
Like I get it.
I kind of wish they still had it because
I was good at that part.
Cause like I'm going to doors halfway
and I'm kind of strong so for,
so for me it worked out pretty well.
Uh,
and then they have the obstacle course,
which is like crawling under barb wire
stand shoot.
And then you're doing like,
um,
you know like sand bag over the
shoulder,
20 reps shoot 30 burpees and for the
obstacle course you have a 50 pound pack
or a 40 pound pack on your back.
They kind of adjust the pack weight
based off which division that you're in.
But so you're using a smaller packs.
So I use the kefauver packet.
They again,
they just had like a smaller pack.
Same thing.
You've got to sand bag.
It was a lighter sandbag.
So you carrying that through the whole
course,
but you're stopping and shooting along
the way.
So it's like you're,
you're learning how to,
just imagine if you,
if you were like rushing up a hill and
we got to the top of the hill and he got
to calm your heart way,
call him your nervous system very
quickly and get your shot off.
And granted,
you're not necessarily going to be hall
on a sandbag up that hill and doing a
bunch of burpees,
but it's kind of simulating that of
shooting with your heart rate elevated.
Um,
and it's,
it's a hard course.
I mean like there are like legitimate,
you know,
hardcore crossfitters and athletes that
do this,
but it's a combination of being able to
shoot well and being able to,
to fitness.
Well,
that's the interesting thing about
bowhunting,
is it bow hunting really does require
fitness.
Well when I did that high country,
yeah,
I was,
I was wearing this,
this ring we were talking about when did
the hunt in Hawaii and I did it like 46
miles over the course of five days,
just like crawling and walking and
hiking and sprinting.
I mean that's,
that's why I like bow hunting is it's
the challenge and the uh,
the train to hunt Guy,
uh,
Kenton,
he told me about these competitions and
I was watching them and I'm like,
I really want to try this.
Cause at that point I'd firearms hunted
for two years.
I didn't grow up hunting.
I grew up homeschooled playing chess and
playing the violin,
reading books and playing world of
warcraft.
Like I,
I was,
I was not like a hunter kid growing up
and neither of my parents,
right.
Like we'd occasionally go fishing for
trout and that was about it in the,
in the stock pond.
So hunting when it was new for me,
I'd been hunting for two years.
Totally self taught.
Like I feel dressed my first animal with
the little youtube video on the iphone.
You following along?
I've got my knife and I'm watching the
video because that's the way I was being
homeschooled.
Right?
Like I like to teach myself things.
I just grew up as a very independent
learner so I'll,
all of my hunting was salt type benefit.
Yeah.
It,
there's,
there are drawbacks to being very
resistant to learning from others or
having mentors.
I think that you also don't play well
with others.
Right?
Like I grew up as it,
when I got to college I was very poor.
Like the team activities you did weren't
socialized very good at creating at
leading edge,
thinking outside the box at,
at,
you know,
kind of,
kind of being a lot more independent
rather.
That's fascinating cause that's what
we're doing.
That's what you did is what I wound up
doing.
And also I read a copious amount.
I wrote a copious amount and that's
still what I do because that's what I,
that's what I kind of grew up doing.
Homeschooled.
Uh,
and it was really tennis that got me
into fitness.
Like I played tennis in college and I
got big into tennis in high school and
in,
in Idaho where I was at the time,
there is a rule that homeschooled kids
could play sports at the local public
school.
So I played tennis and that really got
me into sports.
And then I studied exercise physiology
and biomechanics in college and,
and here I am,
but this,
I'm like going from being homeschooled
to hanging out with public school kids.
Really Awkward.
Like I because you're not,
you're not in class with them,
you're not at the prom,
you're not,
you're not doing any of the social
things that they're doing.
But then you might show up at like,
you know,
tennis practice or whatever and same
thing we get to college.
You're just not used to,
I mean like do,
I went off the deep end in college
because I graduated,
I was 15 and I didn't do like a gap year
or anything,
right?
Like I just started college when I was
16 and I did not have good self control
around sex and alcohol and drugs and all
these things that all of a sudden I was
immersed in in college.
So no one was there to tell,
you know?
Yeah.
The way I raised my kids is they,
for example,
there are,
there are really no rules in our house,
right?
Like they can try Ramin Scotch and
whiskey and they can take a hit off the
vape pen that they can,
they're nine.
But they also have been educated about
what that might do to their liver or to
the gray matter in their,
or we don't say no gluten.
I tell them you'll gluten is gonna
affect your test stores.
Cores creates neural inflammation,
can create some gastric inflammation.
You get to choose when you go to the
birthday party,
whether you're going to have the gluten.
And sometimes it comes back to bite me
because we'll go out to a restaurant and
they'll bring the bread out to the
restaurant and they boys would be like,
no,
we don't want the,
we don't want the bread.
And I'm like,
but I kind of wanted a little kind of
did on my little piece of bread here.
So that I think that's a better way to
raise a child.
Right?
You educate them about the consequences
of their decision and then you let them
make the decision themselves.
You equip them rather than creating a
bunch of forbidden fruit,
which is the way that I was kind of
raised Riley.
So,
so yeah,
it was a little tricky,
the whole college thing.
Um,
but uh,
back to back to bow hunting,
it was this train hunting and Kenton
came up to my house and I asked him
about like kind of like the spear
fishing.
Like what's,
what's the ball?
What release do I get?
What areas do I get?
How would I do this?
I went to the,
my local boat shop.
I took some lessons in shooting.
Um,
and then I,
my first hunt,
uh,
what was my first hunt side from my
property,
cause I'm on 10 acres,
maybe like a copious amount of white
tail.
So I shot my first animal out there.
My first major hunt was high country,
Colorado.
We did like a horseback hunt with a
guide there,
you know,
and that got me hooked.
If this was a,
this was elk came back after seven days
with nothing.
That was my very first time.
So,
and then my first actual kill I hunted
access stare down in Texas.
Amazing.
Texas is crazy.
And it tests the,
I was telling you that have like fricken
zebra as you can look down there.
I know they have everything.
Yeah.
The came back and Neil Guy and African
animals and my wife bought us a sausage
maker and me and my boys made made
access deer sausage and the backdrop and
it was amazing.
And now,
now they're little,
they're little chef's dude like they uh,
that's cool.
They made like bone broth click made
baked donuts out of breadfruit flour and
they use bone broth and claustrum and
they made like a cream cheese ginger
frosting and a dark chocolate cow
frosting and it actually tastes like
real donuts.
What was this from a recipe?
Yeah,
from a restaurant.
They had like don't have you baking them
colossal doughnut recipe.
We've made it up.
Yeah.
And they use breadfruit flour forever.
They did a,
they do pad Thai,
but they use those Shirataki noodles I
was talking about.
And they use organic roasted crickets
like instead of shrimp or chicken.
And the crickets actually tastes really
good.
They'll like,
yeah,
they're not raising the crickets.
They're not,
uh,
I think it's called [inaudible] is the
company that they get the crate and
they're really good.
They like send you,
these little kids are good man.
Thanks.
Crickets.
Yeah.
And they're doing like in Mexico Zilcho
and yeah.
Crickets or they're actually really
tasty.
Yeah.
It was a place to go to Mexico and they
give them to like,
it's a little appetizers and leaving
your room go to this resort early.
Yeah.
They look,
it's like a fried cricket.
It's an appetizer.
It's like,
it's like the resorts you go to with the
apples and the mango covered and the
cell on the thing,
but instead it's crickets.
But they have that,
they have crickets to wow.
And they,
it's very tasty.
They're dark and they're somehow or
another cooked,
I don't know what their seasons
stainable mineral rich source of
protein.
Yeah.
And I don't see the thing about most
people that are like,
they don't want animals to die.
They don't usually give a shit about
bugs.
Yeah.
Dot.
A lot of people find like a June bug.
Super Cute and cry when it,
when it gets killed.
Miskino vegans just slap mosquitoes are
on their arms.
Yeah.
I read a study this morning of gene
editing mosquitoes now.
Yeah.
You're using crispr technologies to make
the mosquitoes less likely to bite you.
I saw that.
Crazy.
Yeah.
It's very bizarre.
And if you,
there was a little cool little anecdote
from that study to where they found that
mosquito is actually have like a,
like they learn if you swat at the
mosquito,
it actually learns to avoid you.
And so if,
if you,
you know,
normally I just like put some on my skin
like cinnamon essential oil or something
that drives a mosquito away.
Does that work?
But yeah,
it does.
And you,
you,
you want to,
you want to dilute it because it's like
a very,
it's a burning oil,
but cinnamon works amazingly if you ever
tried it.
And like Alaska where they have like
really aggressive mosquitoes around.
I don't know why we're where there's a
lot of mosquitoes,
different animal and work for me.
But then the Alaska,
no,
that's on my bucket.
Ours and they swarm you like a pack of
Zhan.
Laska doesn't seem like a place I would
envision having these like special snow.
No,
live very long.
So they're incredibly aggressive.
Hmm.
I mean I'm telling you,
it's the weirdest thing I've ever seen.
We went salmon fishing there,
me and my friend Ari and we opened up
the car door to get out and the time it
take to open the car door,
a swarm of mosquitoes was inside of the
car.
And I'm not exaggerating.
Several hundred mosquitoes like goodness
show.
That sounds like that video that you
pulled up once we were talking about
this with the clouds of mosquitoes in
Alaska.
Fucking crazy.
Sounds like the graph.
Like when I grew up,
I grew up in Lewiston,
Idaho and we would get these grasshopper
infestations.
They like each year.
Yeah.
Locus.
And they apparently they plant their
eggs in the ground and then like in the
spring or the summer they hatch.
Yeah.
That's mosquitoes and Alaska.
Wow.
Dude,
I'm telling you.
It's the cray.
What's a fucking burned by mosquitoes?
It already getting jammed.
My goodness dude.
I'm telling you I'd never seen anything
like it and we were covered with ddt and
all that shit.
But yeah,
the terrible the deet.
Do you know about Therma sells their
sticks?
I do now.
I think,
uh,
I,
I've been using them cause my,
my kid's camp outside sometimes,
you know,
in the,
in the forest.
And I said to one of those little
thermacell things in front of their,
they're amazing.
Yeah.
Wow.
Is that why you're the first like that?
I have no idea that Caribou uh,
yeah,
the grasshoppers at our house and loosed
and we would actually go sell them to
pet stores.
Like that's how we make money in the
summers because it'd be so many of them.
Me and my brothers would walk around
with cages.
She's grasshoppers and bringing a pet
stores,
we'll use them for like tarantulas and
stuff like that.
And then this army guy who was in the
military came to her house and he showed
us how they eat grasshoppers.
So we started eating grass hoppers and
we like it everything,
right?
Like we'd microwave grasshopper,
just figure out every way to kill a
grass hopper.
And the way that we got rid of him was
we introduced praying mantis and chicken
to our property and both of those mother
fuckers a,
a bunch of chickens.
And then we have chickens at our
property up in spokane now too,
which I have a chicken.
Eggs.
Yeah,
Icelandic chickens.
They're very,
very hardy.
Oh,
the winter.
And then the goats that we have,
our Nigerian dwarf goats and Nigerian
dwarf goats.
They're very small goat and they produce
a lot of milk for their actual size.
And they're very hardy in the winter and
they're small and they're cute.
And we haven't milked them yet because
they need to be a,
that they have to be pregnant to produce
the milk.
And we've had some issues with like the
baby's dying and they'll be like,
we're,
we're learning our goat game.
However,
we did have to tie rubber bands around a
bunch of their testicles recently to,
to newt or some of the males.
Once you get them in front of that light
training,
we're training the males to be pat
goats.
Yeah.
Or Him.
So you're killing their balls with
rubber bands.
Right,
exactly.
It's dude.
Very,
very you guys.
Oh they're adorable.
There's a little Nigerian dwarf goats
and we have like little tires,
little tires that they play on.
Their seeds are kids.
My kids love it,
but over each other.
They named him after candy bars,
like Mnm and caramel and Milky Way and
toffee.
Did you buy them just for pets or did
you buy it?
We have a lot them originally for milk
cause you know,
goat milk,
it's very,
you know,
the protein is smaller.
It's very thermodynamically,
uh,
compatible with the hidden by apparently
the only one that's better as camel milk
really was a company out of California.
It was sending me camels,
smoked in my house for awhile and
apparently it's super duper healthy for
you.
And it's,
and the protein is smaller,
more absorbable and,
and it's less hypoallergenic.
And friendly to your immune system?
Well,
when my daughter was young she could not
digest actual cow milk.
It just really didn't agree with her.
But goat milk was fine.
It's one of those we found an I started
drinking goat milk.
I just,
it just tastes better.
You know what I like is the colostrum
your reuse colostrum.
Oh Jamie shows basically just like
playing,
what is this goat yoga?
People do yoga with goats.
They apparently find it relaxing.
I would get so big you can do a down dog
and he got like a cloven hooves and
you're under cervical.
It's,
it's really popular.
Matt.
I think I would get a kick out of that.
Distract you.
Look at the,
let's let people,
yeah,
this looks like something people who
have never been on a farm would do.
They're like goats yoga.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Like you walk out of starbucks
Frappuccino and they go sit with the
goats.
Exactly.
The great system out there though.
It sounds awesome.
Wild animals out there.
Good set up.
And then I have an obstacle.
I built an obstacle course cause I do
all this obstacle course race and you
know what's cool is you can take all
these little little bow targets and you
set them up around the obstacle course.
So you'll like climbing the rope and
come down and then you shoot your bow
and then even do practice like standing
still though and working on your form
and doing that as well.
We got tired.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's,
it's meditative.
I would like to have John's very
relaxed,
ugly sit down with you and go over this
idea cause you also trigger,
shoot,
you're not,
you're not using a surprise release.
I haven't.
I took one class at my boat shop on
surprise release and I like it and I get
it.
And frankly I feel like there's a lot
less strain in the shoulder when you
pull back because for a while I was
getting like some of the show,
like some of the brachialis issues from,
from pulling back.
Why would it be different?
You know how when you do a lat pull down
and if you grip thumbs off,
used more of the latter.
If you grip thumbs on,
you use more the more the biceps and the
forearm muscles.
Right.
I felt like it was similar to that.
I felt like with the,
with the surprise release,
I was using more of my back and less
than my forearm and biceps.
I don't know if there's something to
that,
but it doesn't make any sense because
the draw is exactly the same way.
The only difference is to release.
Yeah.
It felt a lot different.
The thing about archery is it's like
martial arts in that if you learn the
wrong way,
it's very difficult to unlearn.
Like when I was teaching martial arts,
it was way better to get someone who is
open minded,
who had never had any martial arts
experience versus someone who had many,
many years in a shitty martial art
because those people had these deeply
ingrained pathways that were,
whenever the shit we get weird or they
would get uncomfortable or that it gets
nervous,
they would go back to their old
technique.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it makes sense.
Yeah.
Treats.
It's very dirty.
There's,
there's also a series of a
instructionals that can show you,
um,
about a surprise at least is that John
Dudley's done put online and there's a
guy named Joel Turner that has this
whole dedicated thing to avoiding target
panic and a high pressure situations is
he's got a website,
it used to be called iron mind hunting,
but now he calls it shot Iq I think is
an iron mind.
The people to sell the captains of crush
hand grip strengtheners I think that's
another,
another company.
But I love those guys.
I have,
I have a bunch of travel with them.
Those up 197 pounds,
I don't know,
mine,
I think mine might be like 150 years by
about two things.
I travel with one of the areas,
uh,
you know,
it was like those power lungs and then
you breathe in and out of to strengthen
the,
the experts in inspiratory muscles and
the diaphragm and then a captains of
crush.
And so if I'm on long,
like a long road trip and I got to drive
a long time,
I go back and forth between the hand
grip strengthener and then the lung
strength.
I'll just like work out for like two
hours while you're driving.
That's awesome.
It's amazing you put put on a good book
and the work,
the grip and work the lungs.
Yeah.
I'm a big believer in those grip things.
I mean it just makes your hands so much
stronger.
And the captains of crush,
I mean they don't fuck around.
Those are really hard and you combine
that with the apnea so you pass out a
few times and a super safe,
safe way to drive.
Just like you got to sweat,
you're blue in the face.
You can't even grip the steering wheel
cause your grips gun.
Yeah.
Well we're all short on time here,
but I would feel like we could probably
talk for about six days and you would
never run out of things to talk about.
That's fun.
Yeah.
How often are you around here,
man?
We've got to do this again.
Uh,
that often.
Not that often.
Not that I avoid La.
I like it up and spoken.
Oh yeah.
What I do is when I travel like batch
stuff here or like I'm just like back to
back,
like I shot four documentaries yesterday
and then,
you know,
talk the day before,
like I batch a lot of meetings and then
go home.
So I'll go a,
I'll go out to Malibu tonight and then
I'm going to go to uh,
uh,
that,
that human garage treatment on uh,
on the 31st and record a podcast for a
second because I've been following those
guys online,
the cumin garage and it seems really
fucking interesting.
Weird.
It goes back and forth.
Like I've had some people telling me
like that it's like cultish,
right?
That cause because you go in there and
you gotta be like a member of their
tribe and,
and they,
but I have never,
I've never experienced anything like
that and I,
I'm not quite sure what people mean when
they say that.
That's also big profile.
You're a famous fitness guy.
It may be they let you slide,
I don't know,
but I enjoy it.
They like fill you full of like high
dose catechumen before you go in so your
muscles just like melt and then they
have like four massage therapists
working on you at the same time.
And they taught me this how like if
one's like rubbing your head in a
clockwise direction but the other guys
mashing on your adductor with their
elbow,
you don't feel the mashing on the addict
or as much because like the,
the movement on your head is distracting
you from that and then somebody else is
working on your leg and they have like
all these essential oils that they fill
the air with their like special oils
that that causes you to relax and be a
little bit more open to the deep tissue
work and everybody,
they're like goes through a special
treat.
I mean I liked it so much.
I actually,
I,
I flew one of their guys up to my house
to work on me at my house.
They're doing it right.
That's me.
What is that?
That's it.
Is that,
yeah,
that's there.
That's there.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's scary.
And he like put on the first time I was
there,
he was like working on my back and he
worked on my back by putting on a rubber
glove and
under the,
I actually have had that intro intro but
massage.
Okay.
They worked on it.
They know they work on your,
on your pelvic floor.
It's pelvic floor therapy inside your
advocates' tight just like anything
else.
So they go through your asshole to get,
go into your assets.
Something that appropriately a lot of
times we're like,
no,
I had a girl down in Hawaii do it.
Uh,
I was uh,
Gabby racist trainer.
Like she actually,
she does like dry needling and intra
therapy.
Yeah.
And uh,
uh,
she also,
she had me by like this glass tool so I
can do it myself.
So I do this and I go in through my butt
and I do massage.
It sounds weird,
but it actually is,
that shit gets tight glasses smooth.
I don't know.
It has these pause,
the metal,
the fum putting glass in your asshole.
The scene.
One of those faces of death videos.
Isn't that like,
what are those?
Uh,
my roommates in college used to run it.
Those so horrible.
Some would die.
No,
there's a,
there's a video of a guy who stuck a
bottle up his ass.
And then if the bottle breaks,
it's one of those I stop at Thc
suppositories and and actual tissue
devices.
Yeah,
glass rods.
Um,
anyways,
the uh,
yeah,
the human guards,
they went in through,
through my mouth to work on my back,
like back through your mind going
through your mouth,
like [inaudible] old rubber glove and
they're like working on the different
areas.
You know how to like if you work on like
your,
your infraspinatus or your Terry's minor
in your shoulder,
it can actually get rid of pain on the
front of your shoulder.
Like there are certain trigger points.
Yes.
And it's very similar.
Like there are certain trigger points on
the head that refer to like the back or
the so ass.
It's really interesting.
I think this whole idea behind Stasha
and trigger points and how,
what when you're working on one area,
it actually affects another area.
Well,
I got rolfing done a few times when I
had some pretty bad back injuries and a,
I found that to be pretty interesting.
Yeah,
very painful.
Yeah.
I haven't had any rolfing done.
I had it from a giant dude too.
I've ever had.
I've ever had rolfing.
I use a lot of those vibrating foam
rollers and vibrating deep tissue
devices though I'm a big,
big fan.
Most of the time you're not going
somewhere to get deep tissue.
Yeah,
most of the time I do my own and I just
started to begin to have a massage
therapists come to my house once a week
cause I think like there there's a
certain amount of relaxation that you
get when somebody else is working on you
and you're laying down on a table and I
have like this,
this used to like a bio mat bio mat,
like purchase a bunch of heat.
So I laid down on the Bio Mat and I put
on my Michael Tyrrell
and a diffuse essential oil and have her
work on me for a couple of hours.
Usually I'll have her come over after
dinner,
like around seven 38 o'clock and you
know,
like after the family's kind of wrapped
up and,
and she'll just work on me at night and
they go to bed.
Who in?
You're fascinating,
dude.
I'm glad we got a chance to talk some
daily cools talk.
That's a,
that's a sick techno hunt set up.
Yeah,
it was a lot of fun day.
Thank you very much for doing this.
Appreciate it.
Said people can find you on your website
wherever.
Just Google,
twitter,
all those places,
Huh?